he can't block
with anything no nothing is connected
jack he has to go here
can i go here
wait
check oh wait no no no no i'm an idiot
let's check over here right
uh blind
and it can be defended
oh wait i get this discovered jacket
with the queen
[Music]
so i just need to make a move this makes
me survive right
here and he can't oh he can check maybe
right here right
so i can't go there so if i go here
in here
that's ultimate right right
wait
i have this choice of discharge both of
them feel like mate right
here here
i go here that's the same right
and then it goes here
but how do i get out of this
oh wait i just take here obviously oh my
god
he's not defended i don't think we're
warming up now
i could play with warming up now
check myself
jesus all right let me warm up hey cuz
mary 21 thank you for the
tt what's up man i appreciate white to
move here
i can play here
so i think this is the move if he blocks
i blog
like to move
is it here here i would do with nine
normally
but i guess this it's just as good he
has to go
no wait oh my holy moly look at the
easy moves first please
hitting this this is covered
but if i go here he can't get out and
just right there
this is winning a piece no it's not
quite winning a piece right because
you're here
maybe just repeat i'm so far down
no it was there mate wait oh wait i was
made oh my god i can just take the
bishop and mate right
sorry i'm not gonna play right now
[Music]
i like to move
here yeah
it doesn't have to be a check
so
[Music]
trainer cocuna
trainer again and venusaur
wait we're in the game we're in the game
oh [__] juice liquor
i don't know don't know what to do
mike is throbbing throbbing
did we deserve that game i think we did
did you oh ah
because i think it's opening is kind of
bad listen moist if you're watching
make sure you call me boy boy the winner
so i've been playing like 50 games a day
that's you're just 2d auntie that's what
you are because no matter what you do
box box
i will destroy you oh no no no
no no and it's too
soon it's too soon hikaru
we didn't even reach a climax
[Music]
hmm
and we are live once again with
pogchamps here on chess.com
super exciting day today we get to see
what the championship bracket and the
consolation bracket
has in store for us with the matchups
changing up a little bit but before we
dive into all that will be
in store we have to welcome the one and
only anna rudolph making her pogchamps
commentary debut
and uh welcome back and hello to
everybody hello
and welcome back the man who's i think
you've done more than than anyone as far
as pogchamps come how you holding up
there
um well maybe not on this event not on
the second version but yeah i think
it's it's great to see that we're in the
uh we're in the bracket stage now just
to see all the players after having
gotten some games under the belt having
had some experience just seeing uh
seeing how they fare because now now the
pressure is really on this is the uh
this is sort of
the the money like the these are the
games that really really count yeah the
money round or the or the games that
count the most
agree more i'm with you and and i think
you you and i were talking
i think in the last show we we we did
together about how it's really going to
be interesting
you you you learn through the group
stage who who maybe the top players are
right and who and who's going to be in
the consolation
and now now the match ups every single
one of these gets so close that i feel
like we're really
going to be on the edge of our seats
today right really going to be hard to
predict
uh the winners of each match so um all
right well let's dive into the format
and uh remind everybody of what this
whole event has been throughout of
course it is
uh the groups of four that have been
going down for the last week
have now been split into championship
and consolation brackets you see there
at the bottom right they got here by
playing a double round robin uh 10
minutes plus five seconds and the points
that were
rewarded separated uh each individual
player and put them in their right
bracket
but now that we're here there's a lot of
money on the line the prizes are
uh again the same total prize as we had
in pogchamps one allocated a little
differently here
um prices will be um be bigger even for
those who may be finished last and
potentially bigger on
on the top end as well let's take a look
back before we before we review even
more just
what these groups were hey carl now that
we're here and anna
certainly will ask you too is your your
first chance to weigh in here on the uh
the official coverage
any of these groups ultimately surprise
you at the end we're looking at who
moved on and who didn't give me your
car give me your biggest surprise and
maybe your biggest kind of like you
thought it was going to be different
um well i i think maybe the only only
big surprise that i i could see is group
c with tf blade
finishing first and dog dog finishing
second um i think that was certainly
unexpected going into the
into the group stage so that's probably
the only only real surprise to me um in
terms of the players who made it through
i would also say in group a i was a
little bit surprised that uh
that scissors um that scissors didn't
make it through but that was a very
competitive group so those are really
the only two major surprise that i would
say
anna what are your thoughts you've
obviously been watching as a viewer and
we've seen you over there hosting some
viewer parties on your channel it's been
awesome
uh but uh what has been your insight as
far as these players i know you've also
had a chance to coach a lot of them
indeed uh four of my students are in the
field and i would agree with hikaru that
sisters were so close to
qualifying in group a but in the end he
missed out
and forsen is in as well as in group
b easy with aces in that final match
against david pakman
both of them blundering their rooks and
indian finten
making the last mistake so that was also
a very competitive match
and either of them could have made it
the championship bracket or in this case
the consolation bracket for finton
well it's cool the reason i ask you that
is because a little bit of a surprise
here hicaro hasn't seen this yet and you
haven't had a chance to look closely
either
we ran a review of of everyone's games
here through the group stage and
and i think that no no real surprises at
the top as far as who the
the strongest performers were this is
based on chess.com's cap so the accuracy
score
run at the default the default level
which is uh the same the same level that
we use for deciding the tiebreak so the
default level showed that
hafu had overall the most accurate brand
of chess
hikaru but to me one of the ones that
stands out is right there number four
easy with aces right a guy that was
playing a pretty good brand of chess
considering that he really um
you know just miss out um but obviously
zex row as well
playing pretty well so any anything jump
out to you as far as our top 10 most
accurate uh players as far as accuracy
caps go
yeah i think certainly probably for easy
with aces he played very good chess but
there were a couple of critical moments
when he made very big mistakes and
that's the reason that even though he
had a 74
accuracy in the critical moments he made
some mistakes that were too hard to
recover from so
that that doesn't really surprise me um
i i would actually say what surprised me
the most about looking at the top ten is
that foursome was third
with 77 percent because even though he
qualified
um i didn't feel like he played play
great just felt like he did what he had
to do to get through but he didn't feel
like he was
really pushing his opponents off the
board so perhaps to me that's a little
bit of a surprise that he was
third um but in general yeah i thought
when i look at that list of top ten it
makes makes a lot of sense i guess also
i'm surprised dog dog is so low
i felt that he played some really really
good uh games um
too so i'm surprised that he's all the
way down at ninth that's a little bit
and you can see it's in that middle
round there where he was maybe one of
the most accurate players overall on
that those games that you and i covered
i believe it was against tf blade but
his for his front and
third rounds were maybe the ones where
he stumbled a little bit so and as we
look at the
the bracket now the championship and the
consolation
um we know we've got matchups coming up
that uh we're going to be excited about
we'll focus on it but
give me your give me your favorite match
up here before we dive into today's
action
um i i think probably my favorite match
it has to be uh scissors versus xqc i
think that's probably the matchup that
to me phil's like the closest that could
go either way
um so that that's probably the match
that i think is for me the most
interesting but i do think the other
master
have potential to be very very close
because uh dog dog if he comes in with
good preparation and surprises wagon mom
in the opening
opening phase of the game he could also
put a lot of pressure there i think also
david pakman
if he avoids getting very low on on the
clock could also pose a lot of problems
for griping so i think potentially we
have three matches that could all be
very close
um but the one that i'm looking forward
to the most of course is scissors
against excuse me
anna what are your thoughts on your on
your favorite matchup of the day
i agree that all three matches will be
very competitive but i'm gonna highlight
the first one wagga mama tv vs dog dog
because there's an extra reward there on
the line
dog dog said that he really would love
to play against his fiancee
and that can only happen if he wins
today
and will win his next match as well so
as far as i'm
concerned about the bracket dog dog
versus hafu can only happen
if both of them win all their matches
and meet in the finals
it's hard though because waga was also a
student
a student of both mine and yours right
and not that anybody really has any
rooting interest but i i i can't wait to
see i think
i'd i'd have to say wag is probably a
slight favorite there just given what
we've seen
nicholas do right he seems to be one of
the stronger players but
but um we've seen when dog dog catches
his opponent in the right spot what he's
capable of i mean the match that hicaro
and i covered with i think ludwig that
day
versus tf blade was was
insane right i mean just he just blew
him off the board and
so that'll be interesting to see what
kind of prep goes into into here we know
that his uh his coach is very aggressive
uh david has told us dog dog that his
coach is pushing him all the time
i'm with you icaro i feel like the match
at the end of the day today scissors xqc
you know jack played super well but
stumbled down the stretch
maybe xqc uh has some momentum building
here we'll
we'll see what what what uh happens at 3
p.m so
anyway i i i i would agree with that i
was going to say i think the potential
to players play to their best of
abilities
the altering matches should be very
close that's what i will say whether
that happens remains to be seen but i
think if all three players played to the
best of their ability you will have
three very very close matches which is
all you can ask for
yeah and uh you know what we saw we now
we have uh
waga and uh dog dog with us they've
believed they're both streaming
so if you're just tuning in and still
unfamiliar with what pogchamps is all
about you can also follow their their
channels directly
and listen in there um
all right well we uh we have several
hours ahead here
of pog champs battle so don't go
anywhere it's gonna be a blast
the games will be beginning in i think
about t-minus 60 seconds and we'll have
liftoff
what do you what do you think uh
nicholas needs to do to avoid any
opening prep by dog dog today hey caro
uh just stick to what has worked so far
which is i think playing the london
system with white and
i'm not sure what he's been playing with
black but uh just sticking to what has
worked and not getting into positions
he's unfamiliar with at the very
beginning anna you worked with both
these guys right
you did lessons with both i worked with
wagamama
and i do consider him the favorite here
actually i would go as far as predicting
a huffle versus wagamama finals so
i'm calling it now i'm calling it now
but i agree
that dog dog has been really good at
opening preparation
so nicholas has to be extremely careful
in the opening
right okay i i don't know that that's a
uh a super risky prediction i think a
lot of people might see it that way and
by the way the games have begun
um but it's not the it's not maybe what
your heart wants as you already said
you're hoping for the uh the dog dog
versus half fu fiance battle in the
final
yeah but vaga is my student so uh hafu
and wagamam are both my students so that
would be a dream come true for me as a
coach
well interesting here hey carla look dog
dog not going for his c5 the move that
blew tf blade off the board
what are you right here he's playing
playing pretty standard yeah i mean i
think this is pretty normal
uh dog had this in his first round match
being on zextro as well where he played
this king set up and he did not play the
plan on move two
so thus far it seems pretty standard by
for for both players i guess we'll just
see
how the game progresses
yeah and we know this is um a good solid
setup right it's not what he played
against tf blade but a king's indian
setup against london makes a lot of
sense and
for him and his coach looked at it why
don't we why don't we take a listen in
for the first time today
and see what nicholas is thinking about
over there at waga mama tv
[Music]
taking it seriously very seriously i do
like his tunes i don't know the playlist
but it's definitely something i'm going
to ask nikolas what is he listening
miss develops the bishop over bishop
ready to castle king's side
very dangerous though putting the bishop
on d3 so early
i i knew you were going to highlight
that the uh the idea that you
you actually trained nate hill about in
pogchamps one and he used successfully
against eve rod right ricardo this idea
of e5 and e4
right
i'm hoping that niklas is ready for that
because that's a
known trick in this setup that he should
be preventing the fork with e5 e4 later
on
but i did not prepare his opening so if
it happens it's not my fault
i'm washing my hands in advance
no i know that he will not blunder it
he's really smart and has
been working so hard on his chairs okay
but
now now john has played the move queen
moment of truth
a little bit of truth momentum
i'd not have doubt
i'm gonna turn on the eye tracker as
well in case i can see where's nicholas
looking he does
use an eye tracker on his streams yeah
i don't see his eye tracker it doesn't
look like he sees
oh oh he doesn't look like he sees it
oh he played it oh no he
oh no hog immediately responds with e5
uh oh no
where is his eye tracker by the way anna
that's a good point
um i managed to turn it on now so i
think you might need to click on the
the toe because and then make it visible
so he was looking at the c4 square
earlier when he pushed c for he didn't
consider the e5 square the ghost wasn't
there
now he's looking in that direction but
it's too late it's too
late wow
ah [__] you can go in anything
hold it you called it
yeah i i had a feeling my bad not bad um
because
i don't feel like wag mom has spent a
lot of time studying the opening
strategies
and if he hasn't looked super closely at
the games that dog has played
then i had a feeling this might happen
that being said he is the better player
so it's only one piece that he's going
to be down but you can tell from dog
that he's he's very happy because i
think he had he's seen this trick or he
studied it
so um so he's he's feeling very good but
again
the game is just beginning uh wagga mama
is significantly higher rated
so i i wouldn't say the game is over um
when he gets
when he gives up either a knight or a
bishop for the one pawn and i was
highlighting the board for getting the
fans couldn't see it but to remind
everybody
hikaru worked with nate hill in the game
i was referring to that went with rookie
8 but almost the exact same idea and
game with the brook supporting the same
idea of e5 and e4 so this is a
if you are out there playing or learning
to london this is a trip
a trap excuse me that you should take
note of once and never forget whether
it's the rook or the queen
this movie e5 and e4 is deadly and uh i
agree with you and karo not over yet but
a good trap that nobody should forget
i agree totally but again it's hard
because against most setups
normally you do put the bishop on d
through it's only in this king's indian
one that you don't do right
right i'm really surprised that nicholas
has fallen for it for the fact that he
he is one of the players who has done
many
many puzzles if not most of the puzzles
among the participants so one of his
preparation included
lots of puzzle grind um and
for that reason he should be good at
noticing frogs but maybe because it was
such an early stage of the opening he
was still
careless you you don't expect something
bad to happen at such an early stage but
it's like icarus said when a move that
is normally good it's very hard for
players of this level to kind of
not be in robot mode right this is a
move that is you almost play on
autopilot in most london's right and
and so not being aware of that trap but
i think uh nicholas is good enough that
if he recovers from this he'll he'll
never forget it again but
but he's definitely on his heels now
yeah
all right we uh i guess we'll take a
look in and see what uh see what dog dog
is uh
thinking about talking about over on
history h3
um to deny this because he's pretty
trapped here
it's like only only is it uh
page four where you can go so
just trying to get rid of this bishop so
i can push c5 interesting that he wants
to get rid of the bishop or chase it
away from g3 so that then he can push c5
yeah he definitely doesn't want to be
another
brick in the wall yeah it's very
imperative here that he moves the bishop
too
all right i need to think about more
what's going on this game because i'm a
little
losing a little focus um
sorry i'm just really nervous for
playing white
okay so i can just win this piece i
guess
it opens up his file i don't have to
take it now but i probably should
just trading and and getting rid of
stuff is fine i'm trying to think about
how he punishes me
i don't really know um
it might be bad to take though but i
think i just take here so he instagrams
is fine so i have
not i have more time than him but it's
not by that much i need to make sure i'm
not going to get checkmated
so i think pushing here is fine take
take
i should be okay
i need to open up the position i could
also develop there i like this
i should think a little bit longer there
but yeah
just trying to simplify the board i have
this
i have this strong diagonal here i do
want to trade for his light square
bishop because that's kind of where i'm
weak
uh but i already got the dog i dominate
the dark squares right now so if i can
get the light square bishop out i'll
probably will win this game
should be hard unless i super blunder
so looking at his position i do have
this diagonal and i can maybe get that
weak pawn later as long as he can't make
a threat with it
at the same time like he goes there i
take that pawn
i mean no that'll be under attack if i
do attack it so i'll have to move it
dude make sure i stave off all the
pressure
so what if he pushes here
okay
um do i have any tactics or anything
no not really i could just solidify my
position i'm not too scared of this
right now
i could also jump here no i can't he's
pinning my
my knight so if i take i think i
if i take he takes he has a
ps under he's controlled the middle
pretty well if i do that
uh if i just keep my structure
i want to be able to trade the knight
the this but i think i
like if he jumps in here i can take it's
all fine i'm just gonna push this up i
think
okay so i can keep my structure
yeah okay that's that that that's
actually a very bad move
because now what can happen is white can
take the pawn on c5
and if you take back with the pawn on d6
white can go rook a d1 and win this
knight on d7 because
he was only looking at knight to e5 and
he thought he has that under control
which is
true but he missed rook d1 and zakar is
highlighting that will win the piece on
d7
yeah so so okay so now this is gonna get
very interesting if dxc5 is played by
wagon
again i think wagon mom is in a lot of
puzzles so i do expect him to find the
move
it seems like a very natural that or
rick d1 both moves make a lot of sense
um so i think i think it's very
complicated in terms of what's going to
happen here
i don't think it's clear take a look at
his uh his eye tracker sorry i was
cutting you there he could ram i'm
looking at the eye tracker
and he is observing the d7 knight the c5
pawn so he must be calculating
a line that would involve that pin
hopefully hopefully that's the line he's
looking at
if he's also way down on time though
this is the other big problem here is
used too much time
okay plays bishop c6
for those who don't know you can go to
twitch.tv slash wagamama tv and he does
use an eye tracker which is
one of the cool technologies to uh to
show people are looking at it's
uh something we used at last year's pro
chess league finals and maybe maybe
we'll use again but
um it's been fun watching him play with
it on
um all right bishop c6 is played i
expect we're going to see rook bay and
then the question is will he find
hicaro's idea
this move when he took with the f-pawn
was i think partly
you know played aggressively because he
just wants more more attacking ideas
given that he's down but was also very
very risky
um for the future of white's position so
i right i think if you could have had
that move back it might be better for
waga but
so now it's the moment of truth will he
take on c5 or not he does not take he
plays rookie one
um and yeah now i think if dog plays we
should be seven he's completely fine
i think he's gonna go on to a pretty
smooth win if he plays bishop b7
yeah and you could see when we were
listening in to dog dog his thought
process is on trading pieces so he's
very aware that
and there you go he plays bishop b7 so
very good move
okay hafu is we can if you listen
closely you can hear the sound of hafu
cheering on her fiance somewhere in the
world
very closely of course she is of course
she is and
it would be amazing for them if they get
to play against each other in the finals
nicholas keeps the bishop on the board
that's good thinking at least not to
trade the last square bishop but
maintain the pin
correct yes yeah very very very good
decision here
um the one thing though is most of dog's
problems have occurred when he's gotten
low on time
so most of his issues have been when he
doesn't have enough time to come up with
the correct
sequence of moves and in this situation
with a very few games in this event i
think
he's actually ahead by two minutes on
the clock so he is in very very good
shape right now
it's true that time management has been
an issue for him but not today so
probably he was also practicing to speed
up since the format is different in case
the match
is a tie after the first two games we'll
see a sudden death a
blitz match with three minutes no
increment
right right yeah the the group stage for
those of you been following obviously we
had all begetted
uh but in the now in the uh the bracket
portion it is a 3-0 blitz battle until
somebody wins pretty much
you know the the higher seed uh will or
sorry the the better
the better cap score will get white
first um but then it is 3-0
uh until someone wins so right yeah
why don't we why don't we take a look at
nicholas now we've actually got his eye
tracker added
shout out to the uh team here producer
working hard that's awesome we've added
it so let's let's see what he's thinking
about
still looking at those central pawns but
not making a decision better to take or
not e4
but okay it's still a game right he
played e4 i mean um obviously dog should
be better but
could be a very critical next few moves
yeah i would say the next couple moves
will probably decide the game here
kind of funny because when we watch him
now even though nicholas isn't doing a
lot of talking i can tell he's more
nervous than he was
in the in the uh group stage and i saw
you just smile off camera i can tell you
agree with me he's more nervous
and we both worked with him i can tell
that i mean he's a
i mean for those who don't know he's a
dota world championship commentator so
the guy knows how to talk
and explain his thoughts and i don't
think we've seen him this quiet on
camera the entire event
never seen him this quiet not during his
matches not during the coaching sessions
it could be the toughest puzzle
but he would still explain his thought
process so definitely the pressure is
getting to him
and he's a piece down so there's a lot
to be worried about but
lots of pieces still on the board so
fighting chances for wagamama but
david dog dog keeping his time advantage
and material advantage
yeah i think i mean it's basically wagon
mama has to nicholas has to speed up
here
um and hopefully things work out i would
say this is really the
one of the last critical junctures in
the in in this game i think if
if dog can play knight to g4 and put the
knight on the e5 square
i think he'll be very close to winning
this game
and we see nicolas looking at the f7
square f6 knight
uh potentially a setup uh he's thinking
of what dog dog will
continue with there's not it's not an
easy continuation though rookie 8 would
be the natural move but the bishop on b5
is looking at that square
yep but he's managed to close it up
and you know if he gets this pawn on e5
where the trade where his focus is he
maybe has that pass d pipeline so
i agree with your car i feel like you
know is is dog's time invaders gonna
disappear here or is he gonna find a way
to hold this is this is a critical
okay queen c7 played okay now e5
yeah like this this is one of the last
critical moments i i would say like this
is where nicholas needs to speed up and
make some quick moves and try to put a
lot of pressure
on on on on david because if he doesn't
do that then i think he's going to just
lose this game without even really much
of a chance
for much of a fight
so e fight with the idea uh if you push
e5 that will open up
that will open up the position for the
d5 pawn of white
swahikar is highlighting this is a
critical moment um
if not e5 what do you think he's
considering oh he answered our question
knight to g5
not a move that i particularly like here
um
like i i don't understand what i mean
maybe his idea is to go queen f4 and
queen h4 but it's a move that i think
makes it very very
um it doesn't feel like there's a
straightforward plan now after h6 this
is the problem
h6 is going to so he comes back now yeah
now he's got to go back yeah
or e5 again i guess but i i think he'll
retreat with the knight
and he's gotta make the moves quickly
here because he's he is down two minutes
on on the clock
right back to f3 admitting that this
knight g5 idea did not work out
h6 somewhat weakens the king's side of
black so he he could still
think that he achieved something one of
the odd
awkward things for for dog's position is
that this bishop b5 holds e8
so he can't just do the natural thing
and bring a rook to e8 a6 doesn't even
really fix that problem so
i think that okay he plays a6 naturally
i think wagon will back up and then the
question is
does does dog figure out a way to bring
more pieces to the e file
uh does he figure out an idea like
moving the bishop so he could play b5 or
something
yes bishop c8 would be a very difficult
move to spot but might be one of the
good candidate moves to push b5 or
simply place the bishop on d7 trading
the the one problem i realize is that
because of the pawn it's on h6 there is
really only one idea for white so i
think e5 is
oh oh uh uh but he was waiting for
uh okay all right
are you good eye checker i need to see
the eye tracker of niklas i need to see
the eye tracker of nikolas
he found it he found it
is gone
and we are back in the game now it's two
minor pieces
for the rook instead of you know saying
the car has been pointing out for a
while the biggest issue for nicholas for
the last several moves has actually been
the clock even more than
a piece and now now he still is in a
tough spot if he doesn't force himself
he's got he's got to push the pawn to e5
he's got to do something really fast
like right now
just doesn't have the time it plays
queen c2 which is okay
yeah he he clearly doesn't realize how
how good this would be for his position
we'll see if dog figures out
maybe some sort of relocation to own the
dark squares because
if black figures out a plan that
involves any kind of domination of the
dark square it's going to be really hard
for white to win
agree agreed i feel like these type of
positions though are very difficult for
beginners because some of the best moves
include regrouping your pieces with 9795
or moving the bishop back to c8
so those are pieces that are looking all
right where they are but actually they
are not active enough
yeah and but also like dogs is using a
lot of time here he's getting very long
i mean he starts he's only up about a
minute minute and a half
the gap is closing here so
really really seven
gh7 that's uh yeah i mean
i think it comes down to who makes the
quickest moves here whoever moves
quickly here
um h3 is a good move by the way i think
whoever moves quicker here is probably
going to win this game
but let's uh let's see what dog's
thinking about here a little more listed
in before time pressure
just coming he's common for me
now i can push this stuff make a break
there
bring my queen over oh i was even
thinking about that stupid spot it's
fine though it's not a problem i just
yeah anyways um so he's probably gonna
push again
soon what did that square weaken
i don't know uh it's fine though
i want this diagonal to be open soon but
i can't move this anywhere great
what if he pushes again i take
yeah it should be fun i could just push
this actually so he can't ever take
oh that seems sketchy all right let's
calculate pushing if i push he carries
her on camera with that reaction
if he pushes i take he takes i'm screwed
he keeps grabbing the jeep on
is he gonna do it i think my light
square is too weak if i push this right
oh my god i need to think hold on i
don't have much time i need to think
oh man i have a light bishop here but
doesn't do anything right now
i'm being so passive maybe i should just
flown in and started wreaking havoc here
anyways he's coming from me guys he's
coming for me
he doesn't have a light or a dark bishop
anyways if he pushes i take there then
he jumps there that's so
irritating let's just push this pawn
god that's so terrifying
was that weekend uh weakens a lot
you can push me and win my piece right
here i have to run this king away now
but he's down on the clock now he's down
unless there was a tactic i don't think
there was
always a heart attack he finally moved
the king back
yeah i mean this is like very yeah very
very messy like g5 a lot of e5
i think wagon mom is in very good shape
now with the clock the situation the
fact that black
does not have activity with the bishop
in the night that's the problem
is that white tools i think come much
more easily here for attacking the
blacks possibilities because bishop on
the light squares
is behind this pawn wall on c4 d5 and e4
so it's not in the game it's hard kind
of to remaneuver and put it on a better
square so
um yeah this is getting very
i mean i i think i think i think
nicholas is in great shape to win this
game i really do
yeah um it's one of those games where
more experienced players are better with
the two pieces for the rook or
right or the yeah it works but it's like
it's right on the edge
right on the edge um yeah i mean i think
both players here
whoever controls their nerves and and
makes the moves
um i feel like every move though the
balance shifts back and forth
most certainly and they are down to
their final minutes so this is gonna be
a nerve wrecking a couple of next moves
uh with
both knights are hanging at the moment
the f6 knight and the g5 knight under
attack will nicolas take on f6 will he
move the knight away protect his knight
f3 is a great move by the way i like
knight f3
also just the momentum of the game it
just shows that he is
sitting tight because david hasn't
figured out his problems
you know the bishop on b7 particularly
and he almost
a moment ago i mean i think white is
much better here though this pawn push
to e5
when it occurs it just every all of
white's pieces become very very active
um but i think dog he's just he's got to
move here
i like b5 the problem is it's a little
bit too slow here like
if if i'm wagga mom i either play e5 or
just b3 yeah exactly just
very nice positional move to keep this
diagonal closed completely
uh okay now e5 should be very strong for
white
if he's almost winning will he will he
go through
i think you were trying to show earlier
the g5 but the game
is speeding up so much that we will not
have the time maybe after the game
right i just i had to reference that
hikaru was on the edge of his seat off
camera and just show everybody if black
had played g5 that moved david was about
to play e5 was winning on the spot so
that had us all the edge of our seat but
it may not matter it looks like wagga is
still going to be able to change g7
though bishop g7
very unclear here so okay so he's still
he doesn't see this pawn push which is
very interesting
yeah this is this is the main thing i
mean he's gotta push the pawn
just he's gotta push the pawn and go
forward here
this is probably okay it's okay cause
he's gonna still find the way to push
the pawn i think
he also may just want to yeah he i guess
he will
double rooks on the e file then he has
to find e5 or e5 right now is he
thinking of e5 he's looking at the
square
i'm just checking his eye tracker he's
looking at the center
guys say it all literally but he's for
some reason just
not realizing that he's had the
opportunity to play it for quite some
time
maybe he won't get a chance now he's got
to go with it he's just got to push the
pawn
oh oh
no knight f4 knight f4 is really strong
here does he see the fork
[__] he doesn't see it oh he saw it
right now
you see that is here yeah that's the
only question i remember and he says it
so
he just stepped into it but he's just
he's got to move i mean it doesn't even
matter because both players don't have
time they just he's just got to make a
move
he's just got to move um he's got 17
seconds left he just has to make a move
um
okay 15 seconds left for necklace and he
has dropped the rook so now it's a piece
up again for black
yeah this is i mean this is like crazy
but he's got to move there's no time
yeah you just have to move you're down a
piece but you just got to make moves
somebody's going to lose this game on
the clock i yeah just move just move
good just move the queen do you see
dog just moving his king back and forth
now yeah i mean that the
problem is there's queen h4 and knight
g5 that's actually the danger here for
for
miklos is going for it queen after he's
on the board
oh wow so now queen h4 and knight g5
oh he's going for it and he's gonna see
knight five for sure here
because it's just a basic tactics puzzle
might you fight man
he found it black is still okay if he
finds a move like bishop
f6
i don't know if david can see it without
any time on the clock
ten seconds left he has to move the
bishop to protect the h7 square
five oh he's gotta go you gotta go i
don't wanna give him a discovery
i just need to move i just need to move
seven is probably very freaking out
um maybe she was taking the pawn man he
finds it right away
wow queen h7 ah
oh man oh man oh man workout i don't
know i'm just going i'm moving
oh man
i just need to make a move just make
moves just make moves this is a this is
a time crunch right now
oh i'm gonna get made i'm gonna get
mated right here
yeah yeah yeah i can't go fast enough
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh man and we had wagga with the fist
pump
going crazy
with the fist bump but it's
understandable he started this game with
the piece down out of the
opening then he managed to win the rook
on he ate two minor pieces for the rook
then he blundered the fork with knight
f4 and in the end
a checkmate plan this attack with queen
h7 rook f1 was winning
oh so brutal oh man
well it's amazing we kept saying they
just needed to move faster and it took
him to the very last moment but finally
he sped up
and uh and yeah the meeting that made
now black would it would have still been
okay if he spied the idea that the queen
guard h7 but as soon as he didn't see
that concept
it was pretty much over white's attack
was too strong
yeah i mean i i think what happened is
like the the flow of the time
it was too close on time and the white
moves were very straightforward
and for black it was completely fine and
winning with correct play but the moves
were not obvious yeah so it's like a
situation where if you use too much time
then when you're down to like 10 seconds
or less it's just i think it's too much
to ask
of these guys to find the best moves oh
that's really really brutal
for for dog because i mean he was just
up a piece out of the opening he played
a very good game uh
just sort of in that middle part that he
he doesn't play this rookie 8 move and
he saw the 97 95
maneuver i think he would have won this
game probably 85 90 percent of the time
but yeah i mean but you were talking
about it all the way back here i just
chose a random moment kind of in the
middle where like you said black is
black is better here but black's
position is harder to play for players
of this level to coordinate but like
if black had found the idea of moving
the knight and controlling the dark
squares would have been would have been
but
there was one moment danny when um when
he did one dog did mention this with the
queen on d7 and the pawn on g4 he
mentioned that he would like to put the
knight on a better square
but at that moment there was a queen on
d7 and the white white had already
played
three so there wasn't that idea to move
the night that was the one moment i
heard it so it's very unfortunate but
again it's only one game they still they
they play again and dog has the white
pieces
i pulled up that position because i
remember very well like you were saying
this was the position where
he knew he needed to move this knight
but he couldn't get it out of the way
and that ended up being his undoing so
all right well we're into game two
if you're just tuning in where have you
been we've been waiting for you
we've got hicaro and anna and pog champs
we are now in the championship and
consolation stages this is the
championship bracket game one
and uh there you have it right in front
of you wagga barely gets game one that
was absolutely wild dog dog was up a
piece
throughout most of the game okay look at
this dog plays a gambit
line against the caracan
well this is it's kind of like this
isn't quite the hillbilly gambit but
it's along those lines where you bring
the bishop out very early
so yeah i guess that's that's that's the
idea
um well i just said that not quite the
hillbilly but you know
right right yeah um but yeah like
i guess the idea is probably since he's
down on the match too i like the concept
of just playing for the quick attack
um but the reason i made that face
because wagga mama took quite a bit
before he took the pawn on move three
and i would assume since he's playing
the karo khan he would actually know the
the setup
no i love the e6 even if it's not the
best move i really like the idea
um now what's important is he doesn't
take this pawn that's what's important
explain to our viewers why you think he
shouldn't take on f3 since
that would keep the opponent for black
but you're warning
against it for a reason i think it will
help white develop very very quickly and
the white idea becomes very
straightforward in terms of what you're
playing
the ideas might be something like this
everyone white gets castle this knight
comes to e5 and the f file and
and yes objectively black is is okay up
a pawn but it's
it's actually very real compensation you
can see at a superficial depth where our
blunder check eval bar is even the eval
bar thinks white is okay despite being
down a pawn so that tells you there's
some danger
so um oh there's a lot of danger wow
danger
okay plays b5 also not bad
but i think it's a common way to give it
back
i mean because now after bishop goes
back you've created another weakness
like this light square bishop on the c8
square is really misplaced here
so this opening is off to what i would
say is a very very bad start for um for
wagga mom and i think there's a good
chance
he might think for a long time here as
well it's not obvious as far as what's
going on
and this is exactly what we predicted
that dog dog will come with a really
strong preparation nicholas had to dodge
the bullet in the
opening but in the first game already he
stepped into
that fork idea in the london system and
now
second game a car can gambit line and
he's not ready for it it seems
okay but he's setting a trap already by
pushing the pawn to a5
the idea of course to push the pawn to
a4 and to trap the bishop
bishop will have no squares to go to
without it being captured by a pawn
or another piece so i like what he's
doing with this pawn to a5 move
an a3 another move that i think is very
very good here by my dog
he's going to run out of pawn moves to
make over here on the queen side at some
point nicholas has to deal with the
tension over here and decide and
if you're rooting for wagga you hope
that he understands how dangerous it is
and and gives back this pawn in a way
that
it doesn't let white's f-file become
open but right if he doesn't
yeah i mean i think this the only thing
i would say about this position that i
don't like for dog is that the bishop on
a2
these the idea of pushing like just
danny just make like
some random moves like this should be
seven
yeah knight takes e4 knight f6 like the
only thing i don't like here is that
this idea of playing something like pawn
to c3
followed by bishop to b1 rerouting the
bishop
it doesn't feel natural so i'm a little
bit worried that this bishop on a2 could
become out of play for the whole game
potentially
um because if you don't know the idea of
playing the pawn to c3 and redeveloping
it
on the backwards diagonal um i'm i i i
don't know if you can find that
over the board yeah that's a great point
blogger has taken
f3 indeed he has chosen to keep his pawn
up but this
will be a very dangerous position with
the f-file open
white is ready to cross the kingside and
attack soon
why black is undeveloped no pieces have
been touched only
pawns what's going on finally there he
develops one
but uh
but yeah i agree this is and this smells
a little bit like some dog home
cooking um meaning that uh for those of
you who've watched he's won some games
because of opening prep already and
i think he knew wagga was a caro khan
player
but david probably right at home in this
gambit let's let's see what he's
thinking about
i need to uh i need to just develop a
little bit
this is such a weird game already man
okay
he's not developed though that's my
that's my ace in the hole right now
i got my pieces staring at him
i could jump my knight in the middle
right now
it's a nice spot for it and i jump
middle
bring queen to f3 set up mate almost
it seems pretty solid
yes
yeah i mean i i i i this is a very bad
start for wagga mom he's gotta make
moves quicker he's using way too much
time here
the only five minutes i know what
happened in the first game as well that
uh normally it's dog dog who was a
slower player but the niklas is not
comfortable in these openings he clearly
was caught
out of preparation again yeah i think it
goes e5 instead of g5 now
he's gotta move what is he doing look at
this beautiful path for my light square
bishop dude
it's insane
what does he do now i wonder maybe he
develops his knight to like f6 or
something
it's probably the play
96 is about to happen the eye tracker is
there on nikolas's channel
oh knight h60 is also trying oh no no no
no no
don't i just trade aren't i just totally
okay with this
i kind of want to go here and to trade
see if i trade
he takes i mean it's a really good trade
right there yeah
i think i want to jump here though where
does he plan on going i don't know that
should be fun
i don't think i'll lose a piece no no no
no no
oh is he gonna play knight first or
trade first fighting
first is much better he takes
i think this is fine where does he want
to jump she wants to jump here
the move here for black is borderline
impossible i mean
i don't think bishop g5 any anyone would
find here in this
this event i think that's a very very
hard move to play
yeah i think it's the only move that
isn't losing it would eliminate the
train on h6
right and black would actually be
totally fine right but a very very hard
move to play
it's a crazy question ricardo will he
play a move like knight f5 and allow the
tactic
i expect him to play knight f5 and
this is the idea everybody well here you
could take probably with anything on the
night and you want
and white's winning so the i i i wonder
what nicholas is thinking with this move
knight h6 obviously he was afraid
of something like knight g5 or something
unnecessary
i think he kind of saw some ghosts here
this is a very bad move
right but he's moving way too slowly
like more more than the actual position
he's moving
so slowly it's just yep he's putting
himself in a spot where he can't come
back or he can't he doesn't have a
chance in the game because of how far
behind he is
true he's really uncertain of his
decisions and he's looking at the f7
pawn and the h6 knight i'm
just checking the eye tracker again but
he hasn't made up his mind he's not
grabbing any of the pieces just yet and
he's
three and a half minutes he's gotta do
something he's just gotta move
gotta move dude yeah
under three minutes and he got up to dog
again for his openings i mean i know
he's down 1-0 in the match by the way if
he
dog wins we got a tiebreaker everyone
that'll be fun um
but he's just he's up way on the clock
here he's clearly prepared well in the
opening in all of his matches
very good preparation by dog dog indeed
and this is again such a difficult
situation for nicolas
in the position and on the clock okay he
finds this move which is actually
losing but but i think it's a
it's it's a reasonable move but and
especially if he
if he finds i think after taking here if
he takes here first
and her mezzo on e5 can maybe get
everything traded and head to an end
game
yes although he's still much worse but
yeah still much worse but but maybe not
checkmated right away if you can get
right
yeah so i mean again i think doc has a
lot of good moves here he can move the
knight to e4 he can take the knight on
h6
um both moves look extremely attractive
here
for white
he's looking at bishop takes h6 he was
about to play that move and then he took
it back
he does that a lot when we watch david
yes he he does
yeah he moves the piece and then takes
it back a lot almost gave us a heart
attack in game one with g5
it's really dangerous it's really
dangerous so you will end up making a
mouse sleep one day
okay he does ultimately take
and okay nicholas wagga takes back right
away
so he didn't consider the intermediate
bishop takes c5 to try to trade queens
unfortunately for nicholas that means
queen h5
is looking very strong for white uh
queen takes d4
yeah you can't do it right away oh this
is looking like a blunder yes
thank you ricardo for that
[Music]
i'm looking at the eye tracker is he is
he gonna look at the d4 pawn so far he's
only looking at this point
he's not looking at the pawn on d4 he's
not looking
straight up losing for me
oh two and a half minutes left and he
sees the checkmate thread but not the d4
pawn just yet
looking at taking the knight on e5 but
he'll get checkmated immediately
if he does so
it's either fine queen takes d4 it's
over
white's threading checkmate on f7
for he's only looking at oh wait i have
a move
i think i have a move i have a move sent
from heaven
oh he sees it uh this
a move
[Music]
so i got a jinx here it's still very by
the way though to be clear it's still
not i don't think the game is
necessarily over after he takes the
after he takes the knight with the queen
white can go back to f3 and there's
still a lot of practical chances
a lot of practical chances but why is
back in the game out of the blues
suddenly we have a game
instead of a checkmated 12 moves or
white winning
very very quickly the position was about
to collapse queen h5 was a blunder
under i made as soon as you said queen
h5
in this position i had a feeling that
you were uh foreshadowing and this is
exactly what happened
oh my gosh
okay he's still up way on the clock
though right here
yeah but the problem with him being up
on the clock was now he's gonna use a
lot of time because he's gonna realize
he did something wrong
and after what happened to the first
team already i think psychologically
it's a little bit difficult but then to
know that you're doing really well in a
blunder like this
yeah i think the pressure is going to
get to me he's going to use a lot of
time to sort of recover from it
so it's going to be tough i mean i see
he's still in the game he moves the
queen back to f3
especially with the time situation um
but he's yeah i think dog has to go fast
now he's got to move fast like just just
play good attacking move
like queen f3 he was calculating the
trade on e5 but he realized that then
the bishop will not be hanging anymore
on f6 so now he's thinking of
alternatives
yeah that's the last thing we want to do
with straight queens and when a car was
if the queen comes to f3
i mean not only is it a game but with
time pressure there's moves like knight
e4 coming rook to e1 coming like
you might even still take dog as the
favor to win the game if he just
realizes you got to keep the queens on
the board here
right agree
looking at queen f3 now so that's the
right way to go and queen takes h6 is
his other option
let's let's listen and see if he's
recovering from his blunder yet
not saying much hmm
i think he's still can't get the queen
takes a click here and i can set up a
chat into trouble
it's not over yet
he probably brings his bishop to d7 here
what do i do if he brings his bishop to
d7 i go d1 with my rook
gonna be tough yeah i'm gonna be very
tough
i mean i can't i'm not really attacking
d6 because he hasn't right there right
so he brings his night out so now i can
actually attack that
it's not check though but i do attack
that area at that square
what does he do if i attack it
it's a free pawn i can take it it
pressures that
it doesn't have enough oomph to it
i guess i just go d d1 i can't think of
anything else it's a decent move but
yeah i mean i need to make moves i don't
i need time for later
interesting choice that he was looking
at queen takes season gotta make sure i
don't get mated as well
on each too no but i like this move too
now wagga has to castle here it's not
castle the king he's going to lose the
game
and at the same time yeah at the same
time it's so scary to cause a king side
with the pawn structure already being
destroyed in front of his king so i
don't know if he'll do it
it's it's a very scary looking king side
wow okay six okay okay now now it's now
it's time to
now it's time to uh go for the kill but
the problem for white here is that again
this bishop on a2 it's a very good piece
but you don't realize that it's very
easy to just forget forget that it needs
to be involved because you're already
down
you're already down one uh one bishop
here right
okay if he finds a move like knight e4
if he brings
brings the pressure in i mean you're
immediately threatening to win your
piece back on f6 and if the bishop moves
queen takes f7
so could be one move away here from
turning it back around wong is under a
minute
under a minute and this rk6 does protect
the pawn on c6 but the rook is very
awkwardly placed there and doesn't help
the rest of the pieces
oh man this is oh man nerve-wracking
is about to move the knight i would
still say big advantage a dog he plays
94 and he does
i agree and he found it he played 94.
interesting how both games started with
the p support piece down for
each player vice versa and then it can
turn
it can totally turn
only 30 seconds i mean yeah he's got to
move he's
got to move and it's not it's not an
easy move here i mean
oh he plays c5 which here comes the
piece it's
it's a bad move but everything could
come off the board here
so queens and queens that come off the
board here then you can play pretty fast
yeah okay see now you take back of
course
gonna trade everything right
right and the thing here is will will
dog see that he can reactivate the
bishop along this backwards diagonal
bishop b1 and c
this is the million dollar question
gonna be very tough to find for a dog
and as you said if he doesn't then the
eighty bishop will be doomed forever
right yeah this c5 move maybe he has an
idea with c4 if that's what wong is
thinking and dog doesn't ever fix the
bishop then
then yeah black is going to be just fine
right so becca's giving back the piece
the
dog dog doesn't take it
on the one hand i understand i mean look
at the clock
trying to keep the tactics alive
but now he's got a [__] okay but b5
singing too
yeah true
so he could have taken an f6 trade the
queen and then take the knight to win
the piece back
black would have been two pawns up
instead he doesn't take it
and now he's protecting the gt pawn with
rook f2
it wasn't hanging just yet yeah i think
okay but again queen takes pawn yeah
queen takes pawn now is
actually almost just winning
free screen for a car but will we see it
there we go okay now will he see now i
think he's gonna win the game
bishop c is the only move that's
playable here
will he see bishop c8 or not i don't
think he
i don't think so and now white's winning
wagon realizes he's oh this is so bad
this is so bad out of desperation but
now everything is hanging
yeah no dog's going to win this game and
i mean i think it's justified
i feel
and again with the time situation the
way it is
[Music]
yeah you should just take on on d7
don't do it a6 it does play it
uh-oh wait a second what
rouge ga still chances i mean
dog has a bad it's a bad move but
it's tricky true true true true
oh you can take this worried about no no
you can take the rook in chat
brook takes he has a draw no no no
no no no
oh my gosh this game somehow no he
doesn't go forward
oh no he had perpetual chances that's
why he needed more time with more time
he would realize he's down a rook and he
would have checked
yeah um
oh my god that's why you take your time
earlier
and after queenie two no more perpetual
check opportunities
the bishop the bishop is still stuck on
the on a2
okay but he plays c through two finally
finds c3
although he has bishop c4 at some point
but i mean i i don't know i think it's
over but we'll see
what
all right my bad my bad
okay uh the botus gambit um has been
summoned
someone in chesty beach has said pog
champs gives me anxiety
it's true it's not like watching hikaru
and magnus where we kind of know the
moves and we rarely see that eval bar go
nuts
pog champs gives me anxiety so we're
together on that yeah
together it's so exciting i i'm just i'm
shocked i'm shocked by this
yeah well i will say one thing that's
very clear to me though which is that i
think i don't know what what wag mom was
rating is based off of but he's
definitely i would say
not playing at the at a 1470 level that
much i would say
or sorry i guess the rating is even
higher not 15 19. it doesn't feel like
that's the level
of the of the move i don't know if he
hasn't played a lot of games or what it
is but i think we've overestimated
perhaps some of his um some of his
abilities
but i think he's also nervous i think
that's what we've seen the extra time
he's taken
has really shown more nerves than we've
seen from him previously and uh
exactly i was going to add that too that
he's very nervous and he was caught
in both games ah it's almost wait wait
it's oh i guess he has the age pawns
yeah i started looking at it when you
said that with anxiety again
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
this would be hilarious i mean not
hilarious in a good way hilarious in a
oh my god please don't do this to us way
okay no way
[Laughter]
so the black king has no moves if only
nicholas could make the h7 phone
disappear
he's trying all dog has to do is give a
check a single check is checkmate almost
any check on the board
yeah every go yeah okay
okay well everybody what that means
the drama the drama is real and it also
means we have a tie break so our first
match
up in the championship bracket gives us
everything we could have asked for don't
go anywhere we're going to take a very
short break when we return
it's dog dog wagga mama in a 3-0 blitz
battle
to decide who wins the match we'll be
right back
yeah yeah yeah yeah honestly when you
ask
if you should take his knight is it good
to double clause
on his king side okay okay i thought i
had it
you said it was good and yeah uh i don't
want to do it why don't i want to do
okay maymay all right all right
i knew it was good then just do it
just do it honestly you are second
guessing yourself you know what you're
doing
yeah i haven't i haven't played this one
though
you're saying all the right things and
then you talk yourself out of it
i don't know how you talk yourself out
of it but just don't think so much
it's not you have to move yeah
all right play what you're comfortable
with i know i know this time i'm going
to play what i'm comfortable with
but check your king safety when you do
this kind of crap your king is wide open
i know i know i know i know i should
have moved it was honestly fine he spent
like
eight minutes in the opening yeah
making the smallest adjustments so just
like you just have to move it doesn't
matter
i know i know it's hard though this time
i'll move because i know it splits and
i'll go i'll try to go as fast as i can
here
also next time maybe try harassing us
clean a little
yeah like if you put your rook on his
queen it was the best yeah
either i don't want your reps on a queen
yeah
but uh yeah you got this i got this just
breathe
don't over think you're in your head
you're in your head i know this is
stressful
yeah i threw the first one so fast i
know i know i know
deep breaths okay all right just move
wait what color am i playing
yeah aren't they supposed to message me
[Music]
did you guys like those games
i feel like we shouldn't be listening
this yeah okay
especially if you're up on time when
he's low on time it doesn't mean
sit there because you get a ton to
regroup you need to pressure him
oh would like to chat wait wait wait
where where's the chat connect
wait are they talking to me chat
wait wait where's the where's the thingy
ghosting them how do i talk to them wait
can they message me again
sorry meimei was yelling at me stop
giving the casters anxiety it's fine
guys i'm
i'm the best player in the world
except the bottom right oh accept i got
it
where do i go connect chat
wait i don't want challenge wait hold on
i'm going crazy now bottom right yeah
hi i don't want to talk to these guys
it's 3-0 it's 3-1 isn't it
oh i gotta go so fast it's 3-0 what
oh my god it's just whoever plays
that's right as you just heard dog dog
say it's 3-0 which at this level might
mean whoever moves faster
uh it's gonna be fun armageddon was uh
in many ways the same thing a little
more time but it was also sudden death
so if you remember it's not the first
time they've been in this format before
but hey karo now now that we've seen
both players
the game started your your thoughts on
who's the favorite here
i don't it's whoever moves quicker
whoever moves quicker
wise words wise words indeed but it's
the case
okay well vaga doesn't want to blunder a
piece if you're just tuning in everybody
in the first game dog was up a piece out
of the opening very similar to this
even though wago came back and won uh oh
same trap potentially
it's doing the same but hopefully he
will move the bishop actually dog dog
changes
they move or their c5
okay i like what dog house
okay e4 takes away the danger of that e5
e4 move yep though
oh man looking better for nicholas than
that first game did for sure
right he learned from it he definitely
learned from it
and i was i was lurking in his chat in
between the games so he said
he said he was sorry for letting me down
as his coach
i i feel so bad for for the players when
they
when they take under no one's ever seen
our responsibility
okay but it's going to get interesting
very quickly
[Music]
didn't see it
is a fantastic move too though um even
if it's not the best move it's it's
great great move
wow oh
trying to play for the fork in between
taking the knight
well it's going to be interesting let's
see what happens
similar to the first game it's going to
be two pieces for a rook if if
dog saves his knight correct
so he just needs to realize that if he
was denied the a8 tonight wasn't going
anywhere
he doesn't see it
i am very surprised that wagga mom again
captures incorrectly on g3 with the f
pawn and not the h pawn capturing away
from the center not towards the side
it's strange because i talked to him
about this i talked to him about
capturing toward the center but it's not
as natural
it seems oh bishop basics
betray the queens no now we cannot take
back on d3 anymore
dude and he's down on the clock
and unlike game one everybody this is
gonna be a lot easier for dog to play
the bishops are already open is the
opposite of the first game
true true true true yeah dog is winning
here if he plays this correctly he is
sure to win this game
wow and he's already up 20 seconds on
the clock as well which makes a big big
difference too
yep so two minor pieces versus a rook
should be winning here it should be
winning
should be winning for him since the
bishops have very open diagonals
um okay why can go rook d7 to try and do
the dope okay i like rookie one also
it's a nice
nice try
now just push baby push that c pawn and
black wins the game
game this is also a good move however
now i can go with d7 and again there may
be some ideas with a checkmate down the
road
yeah and nicolas knows it we also
covered rook on the seventh i'm happy
that he's doing it
if if the seaport pushes though i think
you're right sometimes it's just one
idea if he just realizes this pawn can
go
yeah it's going to be over right
okay rook c7 was necessary now now
no rook d1 though the rooks are going to
get doubled maybe i don't like that move
yeah that would have been tricky the
king
of one would have been checkmate both
players have one minute though so we're
getting to this tight zone
where there's going to probably be
they're probably going to be some
blunders here
now you just push baby push unbelievable
where this match is going right now
54 seconds for both players no increment
yeah three oh everyone
hey now wagos should probably just sack
and get rid of the c pawn
yeah i would totally sack here but he's
down at 38 seconds he just has to make a
quick move
he just has to move you just got to go
you just got to go man
okay i don't like that one because now
the bishop is no longer supported
okay but now he just they they both have
to just make moves
but again it's the clock right i like i
said whoever is faster is going to win
the game
on divorce
22 seconds 20. you gotta move you gotta
move dude
hey gotta move fast dude
six okay both play i mean
who is more experienced than blitz does
does wagon ball have more experience
the rating neither of them actually go
just go man you got to move move
nice he's done he's done okay he doesn't
have good mouse and he doesn't play
any fast moves either so oh okay seven
finalists
it hangs the rook it doesn't even matter
if dog sees
move just move dog move oh my gosh
okay about to win
uh let's make this
lose it don't lose it don't lose it
don't lose
feels like me he's up 10 seconds
yeah he won point two gotta get it
yeah wow there you have it
here she comes ah
that was a flawless game of tests yeah
you played fast
i never think too hard for celebrating
in the background
it might happen might happen a step
closer to the finals halfway versus dog
dog
might happen wow
i don't even know what to say about that
i feel like we just saw
one of the favorites to win it all go
down in in heartbreaking fashion there
in wagga but dog gets all the credit
in the world for i mean carla you asked
midway through but look at the
difference in the ratings right in in
rapid waga was almost a 200 point
favorite
he let it go right in blitz you can tell
the dog is a slight had the slight edge
and he delivered
yeah i mean i i think certainly uh in
the in the blitz especially it was clear
that the preparation that dog did in the
opening phase of the game played a very
big role um because he was able to play
moves quicker than
than uh than wagamama was so um i mean
very heartbreaking loss i would say for
wagon
on the other hand though i would argue
dog played better overall
so in many ways he is a deserving one
all right
well uh either way we do have a winner
in tiebreak fashion you have it right in
front of you dog dog
defeats wagga mama but we have another
match starting in just moments it's
griffix versus david pakman
pogchamp's just getting underway 40 000
of you on twitch
and others everywhere else don't go
anywhere the day has only just begun
we'll be right back
we're just gonna try our best you see
like this
this is crazy like
the tournament one of the tournament
favorites is out
we might knock two out i might get
knocked out who knows
he's gonna play our best
it's gonna be good
imagine dog dog versus halfway in the
finals that'd be the
most crazy thing ever right
can i hope some music here
and just play some music this is
copyright free don't worry
uh try our best
i think they have the interview and
stuff so it might be like five more
minutes
but yeah i just gotta play my own game
just remember to defend e4 and you'll be
fine
why do i deny
we just take a chill they have to
interview that's gonna be crazy
am i allowed to watch the interview i
guess so right
please don't challenge me to games right
now don't be rude
um
oh that's me up
oh this is awkward hi me
oh hello how are you oh that's me oh
let me mute this we'll just sit and look
at ourselves there'd be like inception
right
see now he waves and he waves
30 seconds until the interview i really
want to hear the interview before my
game
[Music]
but yeah we're just sitting here
chilling
you're getting some reception
and we are back now with our first two
competitors as today the championship
bracket kicks off and pogs champ pog
champs
uh guys you gave us you gave us all we
could ask for a thriller that went to
tie breaks but i'll start with you
nicholas i know this is not how you
wanted your pogchamps uh
campaign and you worked super hard but
how are you feeling right now you got to
be proud of yourself
and your thoughts on on what just went
down i think it was
a really fun match to play to be honest
i mean uh
i knew going into this that dog dog was
gonna be well prepared
and i just think that it turned out to
be really fun matches
in the end obviously i don't wanna lose
no one wants to lose but uh
i think he played well and you know
congrats to him
dog did uh did is is hafu's advice
encouraging or not how does that was it
when she busted
you gotta you gotta answer that
everyone's watching can you guys can you
guys hear her when she busted yes we
could hear her
yeah it's good advice i mean she's
always there supporting me and pushing
me
and uh it's a little scary at times but
i'm used to it you know
it's good well as long as you're used to
it but seriously it did seem like it
paid off because she i mean the main
advice seemed that she was like trust
yourself play faster play faster trust
yourself and in the end
her advice paid off in the blitz right
yeah even last time she just told me to
like take a deep breath and like
reset and don't get like caught up
because i would get in my own head and
like just
think about the same thing over and over
and over and not make a decision
so especially in blitz like with players
of this caliber
it's just about making like moves that
don't lose
like three minute games i'm just like
please don't hang something i'm just
moving my pieces around
right yeah
well we're not gonna dive too much in
the chest partly because we're in
overtime here guys we obviously have
this next matchup coming up between
griffiths and david pakman but nicholas
i hope obviously you and i have
gotten to know each other the last
couple years starting with the world
championship i hope this is not the end
of your chess
craze no i really yeah i really want to
keep playing
uh pogchamps has like ignited something
that i want to i want to keep
playing i i don't think i can go as hard
as some of the other competitors here uh
in terms of
chess per day but i think i'm gonna keep
playing every
you know every now and then and just uh
keep working on it
uh i'm probably not gonna do like eight
hour streams because that's
that's really exhausting but but just
it's great fun
as a coach of yours nicholas i'm very
happy to hear that and i'm ready to
learn dota
as as we said uh skill swapping
for sure anytime you want and i mean i
appreciate any further lessons in chess
after this too i'll
try mostly and just play more as well
because i think it's mostly on me
not my coaches my coaches did great i
let them down
you didn't let anyone then you didn't
let anyone then congratulations
dog dog to you as you're getting closer
to your dream final potentially
against your fiance the dream the dream
yeah he's like yeah the dream
anyway guys um and i know ricardo's been
patient here but i'm already being told
by the team we need to move forward here
so guys i'm just going to say congrats
again dog and
and wagga on a great event for both you
dog good luck in the next round
and um we'll catch up with you guys soon
yeah thanks guys
yeah did you all right as we let them go
hikaru i'm going to ask you to give your
thoughts we've got the bracket there the
first person to move on
is dog dog and uh here comes grypics and
david pakman now
hackman also played super bowl remember
hikaru he was beating hafu in their
games right so what are your thoughts on
this matchup coming up here
um well i think i said it before that i
that i felt like the there were three
favorites so i felt based on the ratings
which
uh i i would say i think are probably
probably an accurate i think wagamama's
rating probably is a little bit too high
um based on based on what we saw today
um but i felt that gripex and hafu
were probably the two other players that
i thought were the strongest
so i i think that um rippix is
definitely the favorite here in the
match up against um against
pac-man as i said before pac-man pac-man
kind of reminds me of dog a little bit
in that
it feels like for him it's all about the
opening phase of the game using time and
getting good position
and if he doesn't get that right away
then he gets along the clock and panics
and bad things
um really bad things have happened in a
couple of
so i think it's critical that he doesn't
get too low for gripex i think just
doing more of what he's been doing i
think it's clear that griffix and hof
were
are the two remaining favorites right
okay now anna i i know like you said
you've worked with a lot of them but you
didn't work with either david or or grip
right no unfortunately i i wish i could
have worked with
all the factions participants but i
didn't get a chance i did see some of
the coaching sessions
of david with alex and i also tuned into
hikaru working with gripex so tell us
about that experience hey kyrwin
what do you see as the strengths and
weaknesses of grebex
yeah i mean i i i did not have the
chance to work with hafu as the other
player who i feel has improved the most
but when i did work with gripex the
stuff that he picked up
um at the start of just the basic
concepts um was more than i've seen out
of any other participant now mind you i
haven't worked with like hafu for
example
and i didn't really do much work with
like boy boy or hutch in the previous
one
but he picks up concepts very quickly so
i think he is very formidable
and um very strong i think he is the
favor but
we don't we don't we don't decide based
on the rankings because obviously if we
did that
then um then uh uh then wagon momma
would have just
been already so so yeah that's why we
play the game but i do think great box
is a slight favorite i think for
pac-man it's impress it's important that
he does not get low on time
that's where all his issues have
happened when he gets a long time just
disasters start to start happening
yeah we saw him even totally winning
against hafu but just didn't have the
time to like take a breath and reset and
realize it right in that game that he
lost but
shout out to dog for just raiding us
with the party that was watching him
over uh the hearthstone
streamer and uh stick around with us for
the rest of pog champs today thank you
for the raid
and let's do our first listen in here
between gripix and pacman and see what
grip is uh
is thinking okay that's fine protect
this oh my god i didn't want to
click there slow down
slow down
i just take like this and we're fine
here
[Music]
maybe here even
understandable that he wants to slow
down he has more time than with the time
he started the game
wanna hit car over here this does do
something right but it doesn't do enough
because he can just
avoid trading and i don't get anything
for it
so now he plays there
what is he looking for just looking to
protect us
[Music]
i really want to get this knife
developed
but yeah he's uh like you said it i mean
looks like it could be a game between a
couple of you know grandmasters here
this is a very very equal very good
position to start and
um even though pacman's down down
on the clock he's also playing pretty
fast considering so he knows what he's
doing
yeah i mean like i said i think it's
pretty balanced for pac-man when he has
not
been under pressure on the clock he's
always gotten a decent position he's
always made very decent
very reasonable moves well it's it's so
like his play i can't critique at all in
general terms but whenever he's gotten
low
that's when the errors have crept in so
as long as he keeps it pretty stable
doesn't get too low
um it's anybody's game and you gotta
tell me you're excited to see the couch
back behind him right come on
the couch come on i was a viewer when
you guys had this epic discussion about
how comfortable
enough would be that's all it just looks
comfy okay anyway
all right kj yeah did you actually look
up what it real what it really means
[Laughter]
i still haven't totally gotten the view
of your new your new pad hey carl i want
to get the full tour at some point
can you do that on a stream walk
everyone around the new the new place in
la there
there's not much to see not much to see
you're like yeah these days you're
you're you're you're just streamer so
you got a streamer and a bed right a
place to stream in a place yeah yeah
that's literally all i have is about
all right well f4 has been played and
grip
just looks like he knows what he's doing
looking comfy
yes on the one hand this is true on the
other hand i did tell him when he's a
light square bishop that you do want to
keep it on that a2 diagonal
and not give it up you want to put on b3
or a2 so
it is it is good but he's already kind
of doing something that i don't think is
ideal however pac-man does not take the
bishop would be a very big mistake
god for sure should have taken his
chance to get rid of that guy
mm-hmm yeah i think if griffix goes f5
here
and then good moves the bishop up he's
looking really really
good i think this could be a very short
game potentially
looking at f5 and also e5 interesting
that he's considering to push that pawn
as well yeah both yeah
at five or nine after the moves that i
think should be played
one of them considering all of them yes
f5 e5 knight f3 are his
f1 is not a bad move either to play f5
to prepare the pawn push it's not bad
i like it
yeah i know
f6 is kind of understandably he's in a
defensive mindset but
it's very very tough on the dark square
bishop here and just gonna mean that
black is worse for some time to come now
i'm secretly hoping for knight d4
instead but that would have been too
obvious if a trap
which rule instead of f6 i was wondering
if david considers knight to d4
but it's too obvious it's too obvious to
fall into it i gotta show it though
because it's a nice idea anna not just
wants to fork here but it takes we've
got even bigger problems than a fork
a a pin of the queen so that's that's a
nice little trick there
he didn't spot it but
it was a bad move of course but uh
oh rick's tricks sometimes can work at
all this the spawn structure though
that's a free pawn
and he has just pushed them to e6
he seems to like too relaxed
now he gets it and he gives us
well what's interesting about his
position though is that after
blundering the e pawn at least he has an
open file semi-open file which could be
used for his queen and rook
some kind of an active plan true
but i think hikaru kind of i think the
hindsight if we were doing a lesson with
paquin right afterwards we would have to
highlight that you know when you have an
opportunity
to win the win the bishop or at least
win it back especially in a position
that has the potential as good as he
didn't do that he was he's been on the
retreating
end here and i was also gonna say i
don't like the opening choice because
the ideas
when you play like this involves moving
the rook over and playing b5 b4 and
opening the long diagonal i think it's
way too positional
it's way too complex and it's not
something with straightforward concepts
so
i would say that i don't like i i just
feel like if you
like when you reach this position if you
don't know what the basic idea
of being active is black then um yeah
then it's just it's too hard to play and
i i feel like that's what's happened
here is dave pac-man
he's got a position where he doesn't
have a plan and so he's just trying to
make moves but there's no idea behind it
and thus
like he's ending up in in really bad
shape
good thing about pogchamps is that i
feel like there will be still
turning moments in this game because
grapex will try to go for some kind of
an
aggressive attack i feel like it will
push f5 at some point or even e5 he was
considering earlier
so he might miscalculate something as
well right
now for sure there's there's enough
pieces on the board here that obviously
anything could go wrong for either
player right so
but i think i think it's a great point
in kara about the lack of a plan and
one of the things that we always try to
talk to players about at this level
which people can learn from is
think about the direction your pawns are
facing and that usually is sort of a
clue of where you should be trying to
expand but that's kind of hard at this
level so when black didn't know that
that
was the plan black started kind of you
know wandering with the pieces instead
so
right but this is a good move queen e7
we'll see if you can bring more pieces
to the center
okay
and the bishop draws back to d5 griffix
was looking at d4 earlier obviously
without the bishop being hanging um so
i'm guessing that that will be his
follow-up plan
if nothing else will be attacked
yeah i mean i think the position is very
good for gripex i mean i i'm looking for
something for david pakman here but i
just
it's it's hard because it's too
close so it's like they're just there
aren't ideas to activate the the
versus the knights or the bishops here
and even the file the the open line
which the queens are on is closed right
now so i think that's the biggest issue
making ooh taking an e5 this yeah so he
did look at the d5 push earlier when he
takes the knight and then pushes when
the square is
is over that's not great
hackman takes it in and you called it
because you said he had been looking at
e5 almost obsessed with this idea
earlier just spying him on his stream he
kept he kept kind of
you know doing one of those where you
move the pawn up and then realize it
doesn't work and now
he might have just given pakman life i
mean takes takes and takes and
black actually could get a lot of pieces
off the board here yeah he must be
thinking that the pin
will not allow black to capture on e5 so
it's true that f65 is not an option but
you take with the d-pawn first and then
the knight
okay david doesn't see that he could
have won the pawn back
okay
a comment from chess tv chat said this
game is like the cutie cinderella game
where she said nothing was happening
i want fireworks too much too much
closed center here no i think
something's about to happen big time
here
i'm a huge fan of cutie and i think she
fought really well
yeah cutie actually i think is one of
the dark horses in the
constellation bracket because she was
improving steadily with each passing
match so
i know like i think she said she's lost
every match so far but she
she should be feeling very confident she
took a game off a dog who just beat
wagon mama so um i think she is she is a
dark horse and uh
and um for sure in the constellation
yes i fully agree with you for you um
even though david hasn't taken the pawn
back the situation has improved for him
somewhat
because gripex has given up his bishop
so that light squared bishop was a
really powerful piece
and now without that bishop and the
position so close this is not easy
g4 wow he goes g4 he's
i mean a great position for white with a
ton of space a huge pawn structure but
these are the kind of moves that in a
practical game especially at this level
sometimes you wish you could have back
because
if you don't convert on this when the
smoke clears this king is going to be
wide open
so same time i mean he's he's playing on
his pressure
and grip is definitely in control here
yeah yeah i i i agree um griffix is in
great shape here i think for david it's
finding some way to open up this uh e
file which the pawn and the queens are
if white can somehow open or black and
somehow open up this e file
then i think there are going to be
realistic chances for dave to come back
if he's not able to do that i think the
idea is for like okay i like bishop h6
actually i like the idea maybe some g5
maybe maybe grip accidentally touches
that four pawn and it slips and goes to
f5
um like i like this move
stranger things have happened then uh
axe then miss clicking your way to f5
and blundering your queen so
well i think actually hasn't david
pac-man he's said that he's made a slip
in at least two of his uh
yeah two of his games i did yeah we were
commenting on one um
he slipped it wasn't even the worst move
but he's but he made a mouse slip
um right no no it wasn't it was the
worst it was against the easy with aces
and it hung a rook
oh yeah that one i was talking about the
developing game with hafu where he
played bishop g4 ah okay
okay true early early but yeah yeah i
wasn't commenting on that one and that
was literally crazy game
yeah so griffix does play g5
f takes g5 by david finally he's
starting to speed up he's down to his
final four minutes
but this is this is what i was talking
about so again like objectively there's
no denying if white
somehow became a grandmaster white's
still better here but
in a practical game the wide open king
h3 is weak
what have you actually gotten for
advancing this g pawn so that's the
worry with the way grypics played it
is now if you know if pacman plays queen
e6 and starts to come over here this is
not going to be easy for white
right agreed on the flip side the bishop
is dead right now on g7 it's behind a
wall of pawns and it has no
scope whatsoever
rook f7 the e6 is a fork but it doesn't
actually threaten anything because your
queen would be hanging when you capture
the knight or the rook
yeah i wonder if he saw it or is just
the fortunate case of stepping into a
fork but not losing material i think
it's just fortunate he wants to double
the rooks put the rook one in front of
the other
very logical very thematic idea so it
makes i it makes a lot of sense to
that let's let's listen in to grip and
see how he feels about his position
and uh give all give all the front page
viewers from twitch
welcome into podcamps and an idea of
what grip's thinking about
it has to be good i don't see how this
is not winning
he doesn't have it like anything to take
it other than queen and then if you take
the queen i went to queen obviously
can't block anything
[Music]
and then i'll take a rub oh oh wait
oh my god he's a sneaky bastard
here i love it
here here
but oh but this is a very tricky move
because now if black takes the pawn you
take the bishop
yeah let's show that tactic real quick
if queen takes everybody bishop takes g7
it's a discovered check
and you win the queen for free for those
tuning in wondering why he didn't just
take the rook or the knight
remember it was pinned to the queen over
here so
explaining the tactics and uh shout out
to the fact that we have 78 000 viewers
on twitch and almost 6 000 on youtube so
if you're watching from the twitch front
page this is pogchamps the most exciting
chess event okay but
now now groomix could have taken the
rook with the pawn because the knight
was in the way but instead he takes the
knight now it's going to get very very
it's going to be wild we're headed for
an end game again i will say that we're
headed for another end game
and you you have to take up one first
don't blunder anything else
very important that he takes on f1 first
and he does so rook takes f1
will he take again
exactly now we can take e6 yeah now it's
anyone's game again
anyone's game after queen takes pawn
it's anybody's game here
so the time advantage is still real for
gripex right that's the big problem for
for pacman yeah and the importance of
this trade was that
after any night jump like knight takes
g6 or knight f7 the queen can capture
the knight so it will not be
lost on e6
this is wild but again we've been it's a
good lesson when you have a space
advantage you don't just want to over
extend in front of your king here
everyone and this if this backfires i'm
not trying to sound like a broken record
but it'll be because just
you opened up all these lines i mean now
black has queen f5 check and
even taking e5 who's what's happening in
that end game
uh carl i rely on you for this bishop
takes
well i don't like that move because now
white can retreat with the knight yeah i
think that end game was probably good
for black
objectively yeah um something like this
is probably a winning end game for black
because this one's like
correct but okay now it's getting very
very uh very very wild um
okay does he block with the knight or
not is the first question
block of the night because that is the
best move here um by a wide margin
it brings the king up okay we might have
an end game we'll see
once again for david uh the time
management is crucial
it has been crucial in all of his
matches and he's down to two minutes
that's a big mistake okay trades the
trades the queens he
will probably win the game i think it's
more likely we're gonna get a repetition
here
yeah you almost wonder if pakman's okay
with the draw because he knows he's the
underdog
or really go for the pawn on h4 right
let's see now grypics can move the king
here if he sees the check with the
knight
this is a big question does he see the
the check with the knight coming up next
move
where he has a knight f7 queen that's a
big question he can he can move the king
here and he's fine
but whether he moves the king or moves
the queen is absolutely critical
yep but i don't know that
pacman realizes how good the king upon
ending will be sometimes you
accidentally just trade into a winning
ending and maybe he'll get lucky
but now i think the king is closer so
i'm not sure it's actually winning
anymore
ah yeah yeah the king is one step closer
can guard the pawn
oh no don't take the knight don't take
the knight don't
you predict these too often do not play
bishop take c5 everybody it's queen f8
checkmate
i'm nervous and i'm not even their
coaches
besides taking the night
play check with the queen or check here
again with the queen
um okay oh
everybody
oh my god he found it oh man
he takes a sip of whatever that beverage
was
not sponsoring the show so you can't
call it out
he for sure sees it it's checkmate in
two
you see queen eight the last moment of
truth queen eight shotgun
checkmate oh man
he does see it oh
man it hurts queen takes a fade
checkmate on the boy reflexes thinking
for
one last time oh wow
so well the grip celebration is real
look at the sweat right these guys are
taking this seriously
oh man yeah this this is amazing
ripping's not normally normally a chest
streamer but just won the biggest chess
game of his life
remind everybody again if pacman had
traded into the king upon ending
he's at least drawing and he had many
opportunities to do so
but here he blunders blunders and allows
queen to f7 and made on f8
my god it hurts it's interesting that he
understood that there are issues with
the back rank so he
pulled the king closer but missed that
queen f7 will just cause the same issue
right yeah that's a great point anna
the main point everybody she's making is
that pakman's
probably realized that this was mate
because of queen f8
which is which is why he played king to
g8 to guard
but just missed this move queen f7
supported by the knight
and the rest is history ugh uh how do
you recover from a loss like that hecaro
if you're pac-man that's a tough one
i mean somehow his games even the one
like when i think back to his games the
ones he lost like hafu
um the one he want to get easy with the
aces somehow like the most brutal games
always seem to involve him i don't know
why but they just do i think i mean the
real thing is just
one good thing is pac-man is a guy who
seems very calm he doesn't really
show much expression doesn't have much
to say at least when it comes to chess
um so i think the fact that is very calm
uh is good for him
because he's not gonna be freaking out
and losing
it's a good point that he doesn't really
get tilted and he has made huge
comebacks in the
previous matches so he could do it again
he could do it again he comes with a
a very very quick opening uh
preparation well he must have prepared i
mean because he is only gaining time not
using time the starting time is 10
minutes and he's on 10 minutes 15
seconds
right and i think you make a good point
that he's calling a car part of this
because he's one of the more experienced
players in the event for those who don't
know
uh pac-man has been playing on just.com
for
several years and and proactively was
excited once uh he saw the first pog
champs to get involved in this so this
wasn't just a guy who started playing
for the event
um maybe that experience will pay off if
he can keep his nerves together here
yeah i mean i think if he can get to
push this yeah okay he can steamroll
just do the pawn avalanche on the king
side with f5 and g4 here especially
since
it's a must-win game if he goes all in
with g4 and f5
it's going to be very exciting to see
what happens yeah
it rip didn't play the kind of
but normally when your opponent plays
these very aggressive early like kind of
kings pawn gambits or attacks everyone
very often the move
that just kind of universally is your
strike back is a more aggressive shot in
the center you go for d5 you try to open
things up
if black stays passive here and white
gets all of the dream things white that
takara talked about
this could be very very hard for grip to
defend even if he is the better player
agreed agrees but this e6 is a great is
a great move though now pac-man just got
to go f5 just
um just all in just push those pawns
and just just go for the just go for the
avalanche what he's got to do here
i wonder if he will go for f5 because
this is
as he pointed out he carry a critical
moment he does play it all right
he does hey okay now we've got a game
we've got a game and with hikaru's idea
of course the
the planning for the king for the white
king is to go castle queen side that's
where it will be safe
uh by the way to be clear this is
actually bad if black plays bishop to b4
yeah that's not gonna happen here that's
just too random
there should be four pins tonight and
therefore undermines the e4 pawn
everybody
so that was a good kind of grand master
asterisk just so we're not we're not
endorsing this opening for white
if black plays best h6 hikaru
he's begging for it now like it's
begging to be played
just g4 g5 just attack right towards the
black king yeah
and then you can remove the bishop
capture move the queen and castle king
the other side and just attack exactly
that h6 pawn is what we call a hook it's
easier to create a pawn break thanks
to it yeah
this is uh gonna be played and i would
be shocked if pac-man doesn't honestly
given
he's been one of the more more
well-prepared players in the opening
obviously he went for this line for a
reason okay
bishop danny danny was going to add the
other problem is he can't castle
the king side so the bishop so it's
almost forcing him to go the other way
right yeah that's the a3 was slow recaro
i kind of like it because it shows maybe
he spotted this idea and was nervous
about it
but still yeah yeah hopefully it's not a
bad b4 because if he starts pushing on
both flanks oh no
why am i jinxing everybody you have
jinxed multiple games today what is go
that's usually my job
that's my job i'm sorry um yeah it's
still okay maybe but black's putting the
fish on d4
um yeah
yeah but they're four hairs the reason
we don't like it everybody is because
akara already highlighted that the white
king has no safety over here that's not
possible
and now with ana's b4 unfortunately the
white king is also
never going to be safe on the queen side
everything is opened up so
uh-oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
who's in the e4 now knight takes pawn
and
i think grypics is on his way to victory
like actually victory because he's queen
h4 check and there's gonna be a fork on
a square
and he even sees he's highlighted the
square i mean the guy is just
yeah let's go check in on grip like you
said he he's already spoiled
pointed out the plan
[Music]
this doesn't really do much this just
hits the queen
[Music]
so now we go here we check
to move king here or here not even here
[Music]
i can't go here for one of these
here we go
it looks very good can't block so you
have some of the kings
he can castle now which is big too right
i can just straight
[Music]
oh wait if he goes here so he has to go
over here
[Music]
then i don't have anything let me just
leave it for now
[Music]
he has to go don't have to check here
suddenly
no he's so close
yeah yeah yeah this is really what if he
goes here
then what was i saying i was gonna do i
thought i had something
and i can just force the queens off no
i'm not quite not quite no he sees it
but then i just need to play football
right
i think you'll see it if it's on the
board and yeah you know you don't have
to be scared to talk now just because
you've done a couple jinxes it's okay
you can you can still talk i'm worried
um
next time i'm gonna i'm just gonna jinx
grip and he'll plunder his queen so
okay knight f2 better knight f2 than
queenie one
seems like uh sorry for david though
because he started so well
he this was a potential comeback from
from the position he was starting to
build up
agreed and it was weird he set the tone
with you know what could be kind of a
principled attack and that when we say
that everyone it means like
it's not just that you wake up and want
to attack there you actually have
natural space and a potential for a pawn
storm it makes sense
but then he kind of went away from that
and went to the other side of the board
rather than just using the space that he
already had created naturally with this
pawn structure so
go with go with where you have uh the
best chance to succeed don't don't play
on all sides of the board there
now now he was just in big trouble so
unfortunately it looks like uh grippix
is gonna win this one going away
yeah for him he's played well
he's just been very solid i would say
well either way we still have a lot
ahead so don't go anywhere everyone up
next we have scissors and xqc
and we'll have an interview here too so
but it's uh
still a lot of pog champs ahead exactly
um the other game was more competitive
this one unfortunately for
david is just a full rook down and the
king dancing in the middle of the board
yeah i mean i feel like the first game
really unfortunately when it was really
really close and just came
down to a couple moves there at the end
and that goes differently the whole
match is different
but that's why chess is such a hard game
those couple of moves basically
shifted the whole outcome from being
very unclear and possibly pac-man
winning
now a situation where in the second game
he had to win and unfortunately
one i think i would say like one wrong
move in the game just as pawn to b4
that's all it took for him to yep
and it would take a blunder of
monumental proportions for
if not to win this one as black and he's
plus he's
probably maybe the best player in the
field at this point and so likely you
just don't expect it
um for those attacking could still
happen
he almost hung his queen in the first
game don't forget he took the rook
that is true um unfortunately for david
he would need to
win the game not just survive with a
half a point so a draw
will still give the victory and moving
on to the next stage for group x
right oh man
well i saw some questions in chat
earlier so i'll take a second to do a
quick call to action
because david pakman would probably be
needing a multiverse to save this game
remember you can go to
go.chess.com 5d chess those of you who
were asking in the chat earlier
what the 5d chess commercial was all
about that's what it's about
go there check it out download it and uh
and give it a try you can use the
command 5d chess as well to
learn more information so all right well
we still got more in this game here
and i just uh i feel i don't know why i
feel so bad
for pacman i just like you said it carl
i think it's because that first game
really felt like it could have gone the
other way and this one is just
off the rails yeah yeah very very very
difficult
and yeah you can tell he looks i mean i
think he knows that he's so close enough
it's yeah it's it's heartbreaking i mean
you could have said the same thing like
also though like dog
in his match against um against wagon
mom that first game was really
heartbreaking too like the way that he
lost that game
but you always have a second chance so i
mean it's
give and take but very difficult a very
difficult way to
rip playing super well knight f2 chad
gets the night out i mean the king's
gonna run and choice of flavors
start just taking pawns or maybe find a
way to get a rook in the game by opening
up a file or something
wow king c4 okay here we go
all in braveheart braveheart braveheart
right you know how that movie ended
right it didn't end well
for i'm afraid this is the same story
spoilers spoilers that's all i do
spoiler movies
xqc already starting to stream chess
over there on his channel getting ready
for his matchup
very good very good he's warming up for
his match against scissors
okay and this is good right yeah
you still the worst cleans up the board
yep
stole the words out of my mouth and carl
this is just good old-fashioned family
fun
grypics is putting on a put on a clinic
here doesn't even try to do anything
crazy just gets the queens off the board
how you win games every time yeah this
is just this is just over i mean i
expect pac-man to resign pretty
and it's just so hopeless here just
absolutely
that's true unfortunately for david this
is this is hopeless
and a very instructive uh play by gripex
after he won the rook he
he just started to aim for trading the
queen and go for this end game simplify
the position when you have material
up simplify the position yep
it's one of those things that i think
new players in this day and age who have
access to so many things that
we didn't have access to when we started
learning let alone the generations
before us
computers when you learn with computers
and they tell you like no that's not the
best move you don't trade queens there
there was a maiden 17 or whatever right
with the king on c4
but for human chess players to know to
consistently
trade pieces when they're ahead you
eliminate your opponent's chances that's
how you win games
consistently you avoid making mistakes
under time pressure
all kinds of stuff so that's the the
caveat for students who are learning the
game now with computers who might tell
you otherwise the computers are wrong
trading queens is good when you're
winning computers are wrong
agreed
at the same time we have as you guys
said excuse you preparing already with a
practice game
and scissors is practicing with puzzles
so both of them both of them are warming
up for the upcoming
match there is one last hope for pac-man
if you can somehow push that pawn to f6
oh you can't
get get that h6 pawn there is one last
idea potentially
trying to win like you make some random
moves like f6
a6 random moves f6 a6 bishop c1
a5 oh but he took okay yeah
it's a fun idea yeah use your
imagination
right it could still be self-made but no
i've taken g7
no chance well we're going to have
interviews with these players before the
next round begins but let's do a sneak
peek don't go anywhere stick right here
with me and hikaru and
anna here but just so you know xqc and
sis are both streaming already
both getting ready for their match like
we said says in the training room
and uh xqc rocket would look like
a pretty good opening to start i think
you said well hicaro that if xqc plays
up to his potential right we don't know
necessarily what's gonna happen
this could be a very close matchup i
agree yeah
right well i cannot wait that's our next
one we still got 70 000 of you with us
on twitch
a whole lot on youtube if you're a
youtube fan almost 7
000 of you you didn't get a chance to
watch podcamps last time so you're
welcome
you're welcome thank you so much
everybody
for tuning in and this is this is just a
start this
is just the first day of the
championship bracket right
yeah i mean i i think it's it's hard to
say stuff about the game because it's
just it's completely yeah it's over
um especially because grip is just
clean yeah i mean i also wonder like
with grypics if he wasn't all really
nervous in the first game he seems much
more relaxed after that first game so i
mean certainly
these are not people who spend a lot of
time playing chess they're very new
it's obviously very nerve-wracking when
you're playing in front of like 70 000
people um so i think just the nerves and
being stressed in general and and i
would add that's one thing that i think
is important
uh in one of the other matches which is
there's a match between hoffman foreign
i think for hafu
it's very important that she stays calm
and doesn't let the nerves get the
better of her
exactly exactly that was one of my
my main preparations in the final
session we had and i think she has
improved but she was very nervous in her
first matches indeed and
she feels the pressure on her she she
said herself she doesn't want to
let people down she she feels the
expectations on her shoulders that
she's one of the heavy favorites
all right and here comes the g on for
the win
david uh at the very least he has a
great nap to look forward
you really like that couch don't you
daddy
we need to get a couch like that i think
that's he confirmed
he confirmed to me that he's you know
that the couch is very comfy
[Laughter]
in terms of his chest position though
the the best thing that could happen to
david is if he somehow finds himself in
a stalemate but even in that case it
would be half a point for each players
and the match is won by gripex no matter
what
right exactly yeah
it would take a pass pawn for the win
right somehow
somehow uh rip makes a mouse slip on c6
and he mouse slips as rook and then c
takes b7
i found a way for white to win and then
he has to mouse sleep again because the
rook can still
come
[Laughter]
very difficult to find a way here
yeah i mean i i think yeah it's just
tough spot knight d2 i think it
leads to checkmate right a four swan
would be a sweet if he finds knight d2
and knight beat well he's he's hovering
with the knight over every single square
so he's trying to figure out which
discovery work
all right let's just tune in and see if
grip can take it home for us
what do i do take but check
i can't find a good mate here maybe i'm
an idiot
[Music]
let's do this
yeah push
you know let's go back so there's no
stalemate here
yeah very smooth
wait is that not me jesus
i almost spotted the mate i have eight
minutes relax
here you know the king is running away
from the moment
stop running sir stop running
back when uh
make him earn it
[Music]
all right there we go
wow that's why he's the tournament
right there it removed his weight all
the
way to the semi-finals
you've done more commentary than anyone
for paw champs including both events
have you ever seen someone pre-move the
mate
um not when it's more than not yeah not
when it's more than one move out no i
haven't
right i mean that was very good all
right everybody we're gonna be back
we've got interviews we've got maybe the
biggest match of the day
jack scissors taking on the man xqc
don't go anywhere
it's more pog champs we'll be back in
just a second
crossover hello mr [__] you [__] i have
been really happy recently
but every time i open your stream you're
huge
she knows pokes my eye and i cry feels
bad man
oh this is something i never do in my
game
i have to do that in the tournament
squeezing the rookie
squeezing the rookie i always forget
to squeeze the rookie dude
hey xqc what kind of fancy chase is this
[__]
[Music]
smile take
hey man love your pal exo
no relax
no
bing bang
remember chat to squeeze the rocky xqc
bang
[Music]
that's [__] useless
thank you for your streams you are a
true inspiration to many people
also real quick is chat so cute
xqcl
that's right i caught it i caught it the
reason i
caught it
oil add
okay listen to me okay if i take
he joins i take and then he's gonna some
switcheroos here
hey xqc remember to jam the man i think
that the king up is good here
jam the man cham the man jam the man jam
the man seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven
i think king block
take take move move
[Music]
check
and we are back here yet again another
pog champs championship bracket match
reaches its conclusion david i'll start
with you
we know this isn't maybe how you wanted
it to end but it was a great ride you
and you played well today if that first
game had gone differently
who knows what could have happened right
well uh as they say
it's an honor merely to participate and
um
i think on on move 36 in the first game
i
should have gone with a check on h1 i
realized just
a fraction of a second too late and uh
that's why you play the games you know
we vote because uh the polls don't tell
us
and we play the games because you got to
play the games as they say
well said um did you see this idea of
the queen coming down for checkmate is
that why you slid your king over
to try to stop grip from the checkmate
idea yeah yep
yep and then i even i even i at the same
moment
i realized i should have played a check
on h1 and this is not actually going to
stop checkmate i was just hoping you
wouldn't see it
yeah well rip dude over to you i mean
right now i'm not you know i know you
got a big tournament ahead not trying to
jinx you but
you played super well today people
talking about you as the tournament
favorite
how are you feeling about about your
chess right now like
somehow seeing like the first game of
the day like where the favorite actually
lost
i it somehow made me just way more
relaxed and allowed me to play my own
game like having that pressure on you
like there's a lot of people thinking
that i was the favorite to start as well
at least at least top free
i like it put so much pressure on like
especially when you play a game
that you've been playing for two months
so right
yeah but uh yeah today i just found my
groove i guess
ikara go ahead no no i'm just gonna say
i thought i mean i thought both of you
guys played very well
um i know for you david in some of the
earlier match there were some big
moments
both for you and against you where
there's some major mistakes but
i thought you played very well um it was
just unfortunate that in the second game
especially
one one mistake cost you everything
difficult thank you yeah i mean uh
they're called blunders for a reason i
feel like it's uh
it's the right word for them because
they do things fall apart very quickly
david we were wondering in game two
after you pushed f5 and you started this
king side attack if you were considering
to follow up with
with more pawn pushes on the king side
with g4 potential in g5
yeah i mean i had the idea of it um and
i don't want to say i didn't get the
chance i i i might have had the chance
and just didn't notice it
um but things a lot of things started
going wrong i haven't looked at the
analysis
yet uh like on which move for example
um basically we just saw that you played
a3 and b4
which is the wrong flank for pushing the
pawns we thought that after f5 you had
the idea that he will attack on the king
side and try to castle queen sides
so if you don't touch your queen style
pawns then your king will be safe on the
queen side when you get to castle
yes yes yeah i mean i think certainly uh
it was a mistake in retrospect for sure
well you've got a great couch behind you
looks super comfy
you know i can't not mention it again
because you know i know a lot of
you got secret compartments too a lot of
cool stuff with that couch
um rip i we're gonna wish you the best
of luck already you've got dog dog
coming up but like you said
i want to go back to what you said about
you saw the favor lose right you know i
know you and wagga or buddy so when when
you saw him lose like the favorite did
that
talk again about why that helped you
relax you just did you see him kind of
what did you see him doing that you
didn't like he was he was overthinking
it
no no he was playing perfectly fine
there was nothing wrong with his play
per se it's just that like
seeing i find finally an upset in like
the top
four kind of thing just really helped me
calm my nerves and just
realize that i just need to play my own
game and uh
yeah right it just worked out i guess
but game one
i i almost dropped my queen by taking
with pawn
that was you almost had me there
yeah we we were watching the mouse but
you recovered and you and you
went on to to uh to take it home well
again
david thank you so much for playing man
it's been great and uh grip best of luck
best of luck in the next round
uh good luck against dog dog and we'll
catch up with both you guys later
all right thanks guys it's been a
pleasure yep
take care all right well there you have
it
the top left corner of your bracket is
full for those of you who played
fantasy in terms of the pog champs
fantasy contest
somebody's somebody's bracket is uh
broken today somebody's bracket is
looking good today
rivets and dog dog will be facing off in
the quarterfinals
i'm sad about bhagavan leaving because
he had a special
competition in case he was going to face
a league player he had a challenge for
them
saying that the player that wins the
match will have to play for the next 24
hours
either dota or league depending on who
wins
true but that was wagga right but it
didn't happen
yes so obviously he's the daughter
player and he wanted to force the league
players to have to play dota instead of
league which would have which would have
applied to griffix because he's uh
elisa and maine so yeah he's a leader
but of course dog is primarily
hearthstone
yep but i mean
yeah crazy i i guess in looking at it
now griff
seems to be a very strong player so not
surprised that he won but
one so in dominant fashion really the
scoreboard is
kind of i think that match was closer
than the scoreboard like you said it
that first game could have been totally
different and then and then
it's a lot closer but either way griffix
moves on and we have uh
we have our last match of the day
getting set to start with scissors and
xqc so
you've worked with xqc more than anybody
hicaro what does that guy need to do
to have his best chest come out today
um i mean i think brax you see he just
needs to trust his instincts and play
quickly
i just want to see more bing bang booms
and wooden shields
that's what i'm hoping for maybe um
i i want to make a reference to uh
but never mind i i totally botched it
totally botched it
don't make fun of me um you're great
this is says actually now you said
he was in a really tough group right i
mean forsen
obviously ended up getting it in ahead
of him and and i i covered that match up
that we had to hold kind of at the last
second
due to the scheduling scheduling
difficulties but i think that uh sis is
better than that last match
against forsen showed and um we'll see
what kind of chess he has here today
both of them are warming up for today's
match with
games and puzzles on chess.com so that's
a good way to
to turn your brain on and spot tactical
motives e4
is on the board all right let's let's
listen into jack to start he's got the
theater mode rocking
yeah full screen board
okay so what do we have why is it taking
so long on the first move
okay
oh gosh
no fried liver
no fried liver solid
very basic opening so far
dude i still don't know yeah dude i was
just about to call that out
i still don't know what the best play
here is dude
this is where i start getting tripped up
for no good reason
yeah against force and he played
actually for no good reason i just get
tripped up here
so this becomes unprotected
but let's go
here he takes i think i take with bishop
i'm challenging both of these
[Music]
not a bad move it's just he's not
playing it because he's run into this
issue
all the time and i just panic and do the
wrong move
all the time i think this is okay
i take with bishop
it's fine
excuses touching clearly he doesn't know
what to do
either if it's taken him this long
clearly he's he's not the most confident
in the world either
true
[Music]
hanging out with him he takes
i like his blade on his definition
[Music]
and he'll take he's up a pawn already
which is
not what i want um but i can take his
pawn
monetizing our videos
[Laughter]
it's bound to happen
all right but okay seriously back to
this moment he played the same thing
against forsen and i asked him in the
interview if he
that was a line that he knew and he said
no i was just playing and now now i
understand more of his thought process
he's clearly
you know really overreacting to the
bishop even though 95 is not a bad move
nor is this position really that bad
right i mean
maybe there's some craziness hey carl
what's what's going on here
well i want to see if xcc moves the
queen here i think either queen e7 or
queen f6 are both good moves
um so i want to see if he plays one of
those moves i think the position is
pretty balanced so far
um but i expected i think it's very
likely we'll get a blunder really
quickly from one of the two players
this is a good move for mix you see
right here yeah i really like d5
accent preventing the captures on f7 and
chasing the bishop aways as a tempo and
a bishop b5 check he can continue with b
if it's c6 well and now now either one
of hikaru's suggestions are even
stronger
now we're gonna see if xqc is putting
two and two together because queenie
seven threatens this idea of moving the
knight with the discovery
and the check on the and the discover
check where you hit the king and then
you win the queen
he's looking at queen e7 he's drawing it
on his board
let's go there let's go to there
[Music]
i i think this is a mistake i have to
try though
okay let's see it let's see it
because if he moves knights i can do a
big fancy play here
he doesn't
he does see the idea will he realize
that he can try to chase it the way
he does this is he goes for his thing
yeah let's see oh wow
oh he's in trouble i got me a headlock
hopefully i'm not here locking myself i
love the way he describes
just so entertaining wait this could be
insane
he actually sees he sees it he sees it
now there is queen h5 check to be clear
but i think that's a very hard
move to see here now you could just
block like this yeah
bing bang bing bang boom indeed
[Music]
he sees it
if i go like this when he moves this
dude i have a discovery check
at which now he needs to try to find a
way his only movie to do this
bing bang
he can't well he's done
bang bang bang discovery check so where
can he move his knight
here here
no here no
and i would do
block i wonder what jack is [__]
realizing how much of a trouble this is
if he doesn't find him at five he will
expect that after queen age five but
otherwise i get a free bomb very could
unclear more complex yes because if he
does
an excuse he has it already being bang
boom and he wins the game
dude i'm ruling it
dude if jack finds queen h5 his brain is
overheating out the wazoo he's he's
thinking though he sees the idea he's
broken
not queen h5 but he sees knight c3 check
the fact that he's
that's a broken man
highlighting his knight and looking at
the g6 oh he plays it
scissors
[Music]
wow that is a five-head response to a
difficult situation by scissors
guys these guys are finding grandmaster
moves only moves
now king d8 is still probably very
strong for black here
yeah you got to run your king rather
than g6 ping
i think he does see it and an excuse is
pointing at g6
and he does
[Music]
i think c6 immediately
okay they're still queen of seven me i
can't go roll them
oh man i think he's in trouble
[Music]
i can't do that oh my god i think i just
got rolled up
if he finds
i sucks he was so close to uh victory
and now he might be really close to
defeat
i don't know what to do here
what the [__] am i doing i have a fork
here
no i don't if i do that he's gonna take
it
[Music]
wow what a game here what can i even do
wow this is crazy check
takes takes and then i go i go i go
negative score
let's let's see what jack's thinking
yeah
that's good i need him to be lower on
time so i don't feel the time pressure i
need him to feel the time pressure
i think we're looking all right i think
like i said i feel like i've been
playing more chess and getting worse but
i feel like
i'm doubting myself too much like that
was a good move
right right
as i dumped myself again
no we're good i really do want to castle
soon though i don't like
this going on here i don't i don't like
this
dude he's gotta move man what is he
doing
you found queen f7 i don't have seven
though is that good
what a game what a game i don't i don't
these are playing great they're
secretly titled players
that i did not think of but i did not
think of this dude
oh man i know knight f4 is very good for
white but it's
not enough i did not foresee this dude
it's not an easy move to find
retreating defensively oh
no okay
okay
[Music]
now oh god i thought i was looking good
i feel like there's something really
good i can do
but why am i not seeing it
go here no here no he just gets my queen
he's going to find it now
oh he stopped too soon yeah i thought he
would go
check
again i think i'm losing a night here oh
so crazy he either finds knight f4 or
he's going down
or a3 a3 is also uh i don't like this
i thought i liked this now i don't like
this
bring up hope too soon ah
oh my gosh guys what a game to start
with
this is correct let's explain why knight
f4 is an important move here
his knight is hanging on g6 yeah
sorry danny oh you're
or a3 also kicks the knight and the main
reason everybody is
tonight moves then d5 falls which there
is
yeah i think a3 is very difficult to
find knight f4 i would expect
jack that he is capable of finding it
because he was looking at all sorts of
night moves
they're like going forward right and the
whole tactical idea is based around this
like this is like not a move that like
might be occurring right in his head he
and indeed backs up the queen wow
walks away from the tactic although okay
oh you guys have three though he gets
that three next move
i'm gonna say if you didn't see knight
f4 or a3 this is not the worst find by
jack right it shows his critical
thinking is really in order here he
finds a way to resourcefully get out of
it
wow both these guys even if they're not
finding absolute besters are finding
some really really difficult
goal moves on on every turn so i'm very
impressed by both players so far
yeah and xqc is calculating queen takes
g6 queen b5
check he's right about the b for knight
that one
true true that's a good point
he ultimately does take with the queen
good decision
because if this happens everyone c6
takes black gets queen takes g2 in the
end
this this would be a big problem
oh look at jack jack castles which again
from big picture point of view
safety first not the end of the world
for jack at least his king is out of the
way
true true true true bishop h3 would be
very strong here
this rage 3 rook g would be very strong
i think
but again both players are low on time
as well like it's amazing we're on what
like move 10 or something
like move 12 or 13 and both players are
down like three and a half minutes which
is insane
bishop h3 would be a five head move
showing xqc woke up on the right side of
that blue mattress let's go listen in
he's looking at it he's looking at it
just now you're gonna find it
oh my god i have to try it
[Music]
wow definitely five head
music very well made bed today
lady woke up on the right side of the
bed danny with the couch and bad
analysis
that's checkmates
what else do you see i don't know
what else do you see i wonder what his
plan will be after f3 if jackman
knight on e4 yeah
f3 would be oh he didn't find it oh
[Music]
there has to be something i can do here
now one thing that i don't know i can
pull off and i know it's
one thing that xcc has not been very
good at is bang moving pieces backwards
yeah and that's this is the probably the
hardest thing for him to do is just
retreat with the fish
there has to be some sort of magic you
can pull off here
bing bang
bang bang yes where's the boom
because if xqc doesn't see moving the
bishop backwards it may end up
end up being huge right oh wait wait i
have to only have two minutes banging
no no no no no he sees it
he sees the bishop can take then he
[Music]
he was even looking at bishop tank g5 he
saw that this is not really working
i actually
he was highlighting it because because
the new board colors i i know i didn't
know i was engaged
i mean this this is still decent i mean
i like his background by the way you see
the teacher i didn't mean to the chess
pieces oh
i was gonna praise it but but he's
saying that because he changed the
settings now he doesn't realize when
it's just highlighting and trying to
move
i mean you could just take this for free
right oh no i don't know if you could i
think this
last time he was trying to i mean this
might be a good this might be a great
move if scissors doesn't see that the
bishop may take away that
is pretty yeah and scissors hasn't done
it which makes me think maybe he doesn't
see it
all right let's go check in with oh
let's go check in with jack
because i think he just found it oh he
just found it wow
and then take this we're good
it's back in the game since the piece
back
i didn't choke
don't delete the vod not yet
well don't play copyrighted too hyper
focused on what he's doing
i'm not even paying attention to where
my pieces are dude
i'm being an idiot
now i get this too
he should take it
out what a crazy game now i check
i guess maybe and take and trade no no
no because that queen is there
get rid of these arrows dude i don't
want these here stop it
okay how do i
attack him i don't want him to castle
right now i think queen
oh he can't queen's castle dude stop
that
dude stop
fantastic move by sisters eliminates all
the chances that he plundered me
it's for excuse
no time and he cannot castle it's a huge
problem
i can check him with this which case he
might move here
he has 22 seconds dude he's gotta go
he has 20 seconds but the queen cannot
stop holy [__]
man
okay
[Music]
what about that night on b4
unfortunately
i can't let him think i just gotta go
what is he trying to get this maybe
i can check
i can take this
[Music]
i can't check again i don't know if i
want to take this and get this
aggressive here
that was an almost bought this gambit
with queen h6
a lot of things have happened since we
had our board up including
excuse me missing that his knight was
hanging on before
yeah i mean it smelled very okay now
there's checkmate yeah scissors
jack just picked it off
wild game really wild game
sqc started incredibly well he was
winning at the beginning of the game he
won a piece
and had a great position right yeah
if he hadn't played knight g5 he
probably he would have had good chances
but
i don't think it was ever clear for
either side until after that that that
um that that white was going to win that
game
yes um excuse he's already checking by
the way the game report and where he
went wrong and he realizes that knight
g5
is a red move that's right here right
exactly yeah yeah
yeah oh and he was and he was right and
it was unfortunate for him it was
it was a misclick um
but i don't think he was totally on to
the fact that he needed to back up
anyway he needed to find some kind of
retreating move with the bishop
and uh right that's one thing that i
think he's that xcc's had a lot of
trouble with is the retreating moves
that it's not all straightforward it's
not like
you can keep going forward all the time
and attacking sometimes you have to
bring
your pieces back and then put them on
different squares
exactly the intuition for attack is
really good but not the retreating moves
as you said hikaru
yeah but i mean for those of you who
maybe missed the beginning this was
absolutely crazy this was a super fun
game they started out with a solid
opening
about the next game starting so i'm not
going to give you a reach
but you should check it out because it
was a very well played game by both
these guys
and in some ways you almost kind of feel
like i mean jack defended well but xuc
almost got a little bit unlucky there
because he played good moves and then
miscollected with knight g5 i mean wow
just like crazy way to finish
let's see what they bring us here in
game two um
this is his chance he needs to make a
comeback so it's a match of two games
xqc in a must win situation
yep he wins this game we head to a tie
breaker if you're just tuning in again
we already had one tie breaker today
between wagon mama and dog dog dog dog
one in
sudden death blitz
who knows maybe we're in for two i'm up
for two i'll say who wants to
i think everyone wants to let's have two
let's see what xqc can do here but uh
jack played well here comes d4
take a listen in and see what uh xqc's
opening is all about
[Music]
this is the roy lopez scam mode
oh he really doesn't want to give up his
pawn thing wait what is he doing
wait what the [__] is happening
[Music]
i take that he goes like this i could
just go
[Music]
take oh my gosh
wait take take okay
take what happened
[Music]
on this
take know what
crazy i'll just go for it
wow
[Music]
wow wow wow wow wow shall we bring our
board back for a moment and explain what
happened
i think he just made it he just yeah i
just basically i think miss clicked or
something
yeah that's the only thing i mean
after bishop takes c6 jack
we weren't on jack's camera so um wait
no no
i mean can't you see that i can't use to
the top it wasn't it wasn't a pre-move
he used 1.9 seconds
so kind of strange right yes maybe he
was just highlighting it as an option
and misclicked
i think that would be a well deserved
miss click because excuse it did miss
clicking the first game so they're like
keeping it back
physically technically we're not 100
clear on that to be yeah it shows that
it's easier said than done to do crazy
amounts of highlighting and never miss
click like someone like accaro does
right i mean it shows like even though
true true obviously
uh once you get used to the interface
you played you know how many games have
you played on chess.com like
we should check your profile it's got to
be in the hundreds of thousands now
right
um i don't know but anyway anyway though
this is xcc's game to win though i mean
he's got a great position
yeah so he's got an extra piece since
jack did not take the bishop on c6
i started game one with an extra piece
too yeah i can i would also like to add
something which is that i think
xqc generally he's played a lot more
blitz games than scissors has like
scissors lost his armageddon game to um
the gripex in the first match so i think
if scissor if scissors isn't able to
convert this i think
the odds favor xqc very heavily in a
blitz game
i was just going to explain once again
the format because he carries already
foreshadowing a sudden death and that's
what happens when the match is one one
if it's a tie xqc winning this game it
will be a tie
then we gonna get to see a sudden death
blitz game three minutes no increment
and i agree
that xqc is more experienced in blitz
games
yeah and again we already said we
already had one sudden death tie breaker
today
it's more exciting than sudden death
dodgeball it really is my
to me it is um but uh yeah
we're gonna have to ask jack what
happened with bishop d7 i i don't know
because we had we had him off camera he
wasn't to the stream i don't know that
he was highlighting that square so
something just
maybe he just forgot he could take back
right
all right okay if xcc takes the queen
here i think he's in great shape
yep um that hits the rook
looking at knight takes d4
which also makes perfect sense i think
luckily for him in comparison to game
one
here he has a piece up just like he did
in the previous game but also the
position is very natural he can just
make natural moves and
not go wrong while in the other game his
bishop on h3 was hanging the king was
still on e8 on an open file
so it was way more difficult i think
it's also important that xcc does not
take too much time here
yep yeah but he i think he's looking at
night g5 or
something like that as well so yeah more
aggressive
and then taking back the pawn which is
possible too the only
potential bad road of that is when
you're just winning a lot of times you
just want to push yourself play fast
play simple
allow the trades to happen kind of don't
fight it right um
right but okay he does go for knight g5
not a bad move
at all not a bad move at all completely
reasonable
very aggressive once again he's uh his
intuition for attack is great
he was looking at queen e7 as a
potential defense for black but i think
he realized that's not really working
right
oh so so apparently he played bishop d7
his idea
scissors was to play bishop d7 right
away and not a6
then he played a6 he was so frustrated
that he immediately just moved the
bishop
right away oh wow interesting okay so
thank you to those who ever informed a
car of that that was watching
watching scissors stream um that's
really unfortunate he was tilted by not
playing that move first
crazy crazy let's take a listen and
see what jack's thinking now
um i don't think this is what i want to
do
dude my
i don't think this is what i want to do
i'm not even close to castling he could
castle right now
this is all terrible this is not looking
good this is
not not what you want dude my rooks
aren't going to be connected this is so
bad dude oh i'm so sad that i did that
all because of one terrible move
yep
it's not all lost because i go here
right
then i check then i take this threaten
this so then he can't castle
positive attitude
it's recoverable but it's not looking
good
you should probably just like go there i
guess i don't [__] i don't
know like this is calculating queen two
g4 and then h5 for black
so bad
[Music]
as you said hikaru he doesn't really
want to move backwards with the pieces
he wants to protect the bishop yeah i
mean
if he doesn't want to move backwards he
should just take that he should just
take the knight off the board
yeah what you're saying was looking at
queen g4
yeah but i agree hikaru if you're not
going to go backwards just take the
knight but yeah he doesn't he doesn't
like backing up his piece
that's right but we've learned that
yeah ouija board would be a very risky
movement
i mean i don't like it at all yeah yeah
i would just take tonight get that
knight off the board and just play
in the middle that's what i would do oh
and he does it
good and now if he gets castled
okay this is also fine queen takes
deeper great move yeah
also notice that black won't be able to
castle now this is the other thing right
and if black does not play c5 there's
gonna be a really dirty uh double
double attack on the two
it's hovering over the queen he's
already going to queen
[Music]
they both work because he has
he does it he does it yeah it's it's the
other order but yeah
but but it but it works right he sees
the more
complex ones pieces are so weird
i'm sorry if he gets out of this i will
lose
my mind
he's gonna go for the pawn but he's
played super well
like i i he's gonna be dangerous to to
want to face in the uh in the blitz
this is right yeah there's no way
that he gets out of this play dude
it's just too smart it's just too smart
it's incredible i'm going i'm going to
say that forever this is it's just
he's very smart and and he deserves he
deserves a comeback he plays so well in
game one as well
seriously oh he does and he's and he's
in game one again everybody
through the track clean shot that was
why he did it
please watch he goes please work
i feel like everything out of his mouth
is a clippable moment like please work
i mean it's just like he's just awesome
by the way i was going to say the one
thing that i do like is their tooth
is that he's starting to see the
patterns better like the screaming c6
check happened in his game against hafu
from a different position
um and uh in the first game that knight
c3 check he's had many times
so um so yeah so he's he's he should win
this game
oh yeah
let's go one two one baby
oh wow one to one baby that's right
oh man that is right jack resigns
because he's a rook and please down uh
but yeah
okay uh gotta come back don't go
anywhere
i thought it was wishful thinking but
apparently not xqc delivers in the
clutch
and we will have a sudden death
tiebreaker if you change the channel now
it is a you problem
pogchamps returns in just a few minutes
see that's what i thought about that was
my play that i thought was the best
uh the type of recruit for the playoffs
is the three plus zero game the higher c
that gets white if that game is drawn
then the game will be replayed with
colors reverse
oh that was that the way that wasn't
[Music]
good
to win first to win threesome no
comments got it
[Music]
oh i don't know how i feel about that
about speed thinking right now
[Music]
so why was that better oh
because of possible check
[Music]
the computer really wants these pawns
okay i'll i'm ready
[Music]
so
and after two just absolutely wild games
gotta give one more big shout out to the
wildest game right now
in the in the chess multiverse go to
go.chess.com5dchess
and give it a try or you can go right to
steampowered.com 5ds is a game
that a lot of people are playing i know
some would say 2d chess is hard enough
and i would understand those people who
would say 2d chess is hard enough but go
give 5d chess a try
as we give xqc and scissors a try and
tiebreakers here oh my god
i'm excited anna this is going to be
awesome can't wait it's gonna be epic an
excuse
with the over 96 percent accuracy in his
game to
water play water play by the warlord
earning
the tiebreaker this is sudden death
three minutes for
both players no increment right yeah
yeah i think this probably favors xc
very slightly just because of the fact
that he's played a lot of bullet chests
that's the only thing i would say and
scissors was slow against um
against gripex those are the only two
reasons i think something could happen
right we'll see yeah and for those who
who maybe forgot
day one of pogchamps oh we have a
blunder oh there's a blunder
right right away there's a big blunder
oh he misses it okay
he missed it he missed it okay
i think this is the thought afterwards i
think scissors
yeah you thought i was about to see
action scissors
and grippix had an armageddon game day
one our first match we covered hikara
remember was
was armageddon tiebreaker so
so scissors has been here that's the one
thing we can say for him he's been in a
tie breaker before
it's already tense situation right at
the start okay let's see what xcc is
going to do
he's got to stop the pawn from being
captured
hopefully he doesn't bother the same
thing he didn't play he could have taken
a similar point
but he brought the bishop out he brought
the bishop out so it's not a checkmate
okay oh wow
he's got queen c6 if he finds it yeah
if he finds the queen move it's still
very much a game but he has to find the
queen over
the only looking at queen b6 and knight
d7 those are not the right moves
unfortunately
26 is the only move exactly the only way
to save the rook
he is touching every single piece he's
clicking on all of them b8 rook
the b89 the a8 rook the a7 pawn
i'm pretty much here
what to look forward dude here dude
i don't know i'm i'm minus one i i lost
i guess jeez
[__] me dude not the worst
it's not over we never know
[Music]
a big comeback
i think i can escape
it's gotta move just move here and just
go for it
because he's down to his final minute
and missing that rook
unfortunately from the corner that he
blundered
i need to get this out of here
the xcc has to move fast though just
fake move
i don't like the position my queen is in
but i'm up a lot of material
so it's fine uh
sure let's trade oh i know scissors
[Music]
oh my god i thought yeah for a second
that was almost really bad
it was almost really bad yeah that's
exactly almost
clean yeah wow oh man what
what ask if you didn't take the queen
melt down
i'm meltdown unfortunately and down
and down
[Music]
he didn't take my queen dude
oh no what are you doing
oh my god
okay you got a piece that's fine um
we trade
[Music]
this is a very sad story for execution
[Applause]
give me the white pieces
i swear i was just about to say it and
it happened so fast
oh my god
holy crap excuse me the miracle
come back still mate he was giving up
his pieces on purpose and he achieved a
stalemate
i didn't think jack was gonna play so
fast i was about to say now queen h3 is
made between age seven and then
when history was made queen h7 stalemate
and
the latter happened oh my gosh
excuse me with five seconds left on the
clock manages to
get into a stalemate position and force
the draw
i threw up my back i threw up my back
okay
we're playing again are you okay ready
one more time are we breaking around at
least one more oh
okay here we go oh my god
jack is freaking out incredible
that was insane
oh my god it's unbelievable
i was already so sad for xqc because he
played so well in the first two games
this would have been
so unfair to him to go down like this
and you called it he also only had five
seconds all jack had to do was
any move but that right any move yeah
any move and he wins
yeah wow oh my gosh poor guy
oh my gosh so tense
xqc was going nuts that was hilarious
all right okay so once again the same
the same format
sudden death whoever wins this wins the
match we keep playing until someone wins
so if they draw again they'll flip
colors and go again
it's double sudden death dodgeball
wow i did wow
oh my gosh
at least he's up on the clock here and
xucci has always got good positions with
white
so yeah last time he only kind of got
unlucky with he clearly missed that
whole diagonal idea because remember the
move before queen b7 he missed queen
takes g2
so he's true true if it wasn't for that
idea he was playing well so we'll see if
it pays off now
it's off to a very good start here
definitely and psychologically
yeah absolutely escaping from a
completely lost position gives you such
a boost in moral so he must be feeling
great well neither of them are saying
much we can see them on camera and there
we go let's let's tune in a little bit
with jack see how he's recovering
okay
i'm under time pressure gotta remember
that
god i remember that
um um that's not good
i blundered i blundered i choked all
right i think
we're fine [__]
i don't like that
[Music]
i don't like this at all i like
none of this he doesn't see him actually
throwing here
you can take it with his knight he
doesn't see it
i should have just taken dude what am i
doing
what am i doing what am i doing dude
what am i doing what am i doing
oh i'm throwing i actually threw i
actually threw so hard
no no no no no no no no no man
oh no no no and now we oh no dude
why i mean i have this but
ah no not like this man not like this
dude
ah poor jack i like this
like we're about to storm the castle
he's so focused he knows that this is
his chance
gotta move though didn't move
up with the bait
yeah just simplifying the position very
good yeah it's gonna move though it's
gotta move
fast
[Music]
seconds you gotta move quickly gotta
move both players just need to move just
move
move whoever moves faster wins at this
point whoever moves faster is going to
win here he's got to move he's got to
[Music]
move
move by jack there to open things up
oh man
both players just have to go just have
to go here exactly
oh man every move is so tense here like
you just they both have to just move
final 30 seconds oh final minute 30
seconds
gotta move oh come on just move just
move just move
just move what do you need to go he's
gotta go will he play knight f6 really
six make a move and he moved oh my god
he found knight f6 he did
oh my god found it brilliant movement
now he's got to be involved
both players have to go move the rook
remove the queen he's got to move he's
got to move oh man
excuse he's playing so well but now
misses the rook
on a1 hanging with a check just move
move
he's gotta move he's gotta move oh no
nine seconds left move they both have to
go i mean just like instant move
any move takes the bishop he's playing
well he his
position is winning but the time the
time remove it
oh oh no he doesn't have time good
meeting
he would have made so soon he's gonna
lose on time
he's gonna lose some time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh
oh man
i'm speechless xqc played so well this
game he even found
knight f6 check with just 20 seconds
on the clock he played knight f6 which
is a winning move but not an easy one to
play at all yeah
he's beautiful but but seriously i agree
and i've never seen xqc play better
chess maybe i mean but but the clock
caught up with him and jack held on to
overcome the stalemate
oh my god we'll recap all of this have
interviews and everything in just a few
minutes don't go anywhere
final moments of the wildest day of pog
champs ever
we'll be right back
[Music]
so
and we are with the the man of the hour
jack oh gosh
you set it off off fair buddy it was
what was that right i don't know what
that was i don't know
i don't have an answer for you it was
content is what it was it was great
content
and we had this moment on the board when
when you clearly just wanted more games
that was all that's why you played queen
takes h7 right that was that was why
uh yeah i i just figured
i just assumed i was moving so quickly i
just assumed there was a place for his
king to go
i wasn't even looking at checkmate i
just wanted to i don't know what i was
doing
obviously i'm just teasing you man i
mean yeah you won in the end so
obviously you know highlighting how we
got there i'm just i don't feel like i
deserved that win though
i take the win though we take those it
was it was wild and and you guys you
guys both played super well can i just
say from start to finish i mean
all three of us here me and carl and
anna were just from the very beginning
you guys had a back and forth
crazy battle and you know hats off to
xqc of course as well but
yeah then in the end at one point in
this game jack did you realize despite
the fact that you were worse
you started the video last one yeah you
started picking up the pace right about
here where you just started moving
quickly like at what point did you
realize
you just had to go as fast as you could
um
i don't know uh i was just feeling way
more confident
um because i was throwing away the games
earlier
and i knew that we were even er i was
even right here
no i was up on material no this one you
were losing
oh i was down on material i just knew
that he was lower on
the time in the previous matches so if i
just tried to go
quickly and put the time pressure on him
then that would um
you know hopefully work out in my favor
and it did
anna or ricardo go ahead i just no more
questions right now i mean i i was i was
actually the one question i had was in
this
the second game um when you played this
mistake yeah there were
a lot of bad ones like well well just
what happened i guess is really the
question because we weren't listening
um when i moved the bishop to protect
there yeah like he took your height and
then you moved your bishop
yeah like at the very start yeah right
here oh oh oh
i wanted to do that move before i pushed
the pawn
to uh uh the is that asics
yeah before i push the pawn to a6 i
wanted to make that move before
and i turned my music all the way up i
was absolutely jamming out and i just
wasn't thinking man it was the worst i
was so mad at myself
i wanted to do that move before i push
the a pawn
certainly have an amazing playlist jack
i wanted to get a copy of that
because we were jamming we were jumping
to
how do you see yourself in terms of the
consolation record and your chances now
that you move on and your opponent will
be either connor eats pants or cutie
cinderella
you know all i gotta do is review those
games firstly
and play a little bit slower because i
feel like in the first two games
even though i made mistakes i had a lot
of time left so i should have just taken
my time more
and you know go over all the options
because i just definitely have been
rushing and making a lot of mistakes
it is good that's a good takeaway
self-reflection right i mean because
even in that game with the stalemate
right yes you were
yes you got unlucky but also like you
had you had some time right you could
have slowed down a little bit
so quickly when i have so much time left
that was bad well um
so the takeaway there right slow down a
little bit but
also like i said you guys gave us you
guys gave us the uh
the most exciting match i mean i feel
like i've covered a part of either
either one of these events it was a lot
of fun
that was very intense i was definitely
sweating
i don't deserve that win but that was so
intense
i mean i i guess i think the match could
have gone either way honestly yeah it
was it was close
well it just we have a guest who is
joining us
i think someone will be joining us in a
moment
right now i was slowing down yeah hey
man
excuse xqc dude i have not seen better
better chat you played fantastic chess i
know that didn't go how you wanted in
the end man but that was that was
awesome that was awesome
awesome games for us oh thanks you
played amazing that is true
well yeah i definitely thought i'm
insane moves definitely thought i was
losing
no no i definitely thought i was losing
that game there
even go ahead go ahead
i was going to say that one of the
examples of it was almost like here it
was almost like you were playing too
good of moves for your own good you
actually found this move knight f6 check
with 20 seconds left
the idea of deflecting the queen but at
what point here did you start to realize
with the clock 18 seconds that you just
that you know you had to speed up right
and unfortunately you fell just a couple
seconds short but
what was going through your head toward
the final moments of this game
asking you felix yep yeah
um i thought i had some sort of uh some
sort of
crossfire check menu coming
um and then you start
moving as pawns and i was like okay i
know this is going
and uh i i didn't want to still made it
so i just [__] kept playing but
i had no idea what i was doing with
those pawns i just had to make moves
yep i noticed
yeah i was going to add something to it
i was just going to say like i
i would actually agree as for for ux you
see i i did think it was the best chess
that you've played throughout the event
um by far like you were finding a lot of
good moves and like in that
in the early second game yeah there was
this discovery check in the first game
that you've had many
times before and then the second game
seeing this queen c4 queen c6 check move
hitting the king and rook was
just like your game against hoffman the
previous round so i thought you played
very well and you
kind of things started clicking so it
was great to watch thanks man
um it was as epic to watch in 1996
accuracy you had in that game felix that
that's insane you played like
a very experienced title player yeah but
honestly it to me it felt like um
that that game didn't feel really
fulfilling i even tapped out because i
had to go look if it was actually him
playing at double check because
i thought i'd shoot up for another match
because he was just hanging his pieces
and i was just getting and i was like
dude this is free little like it's
with the knight you're talking about in
the yeah
yeah you did the whole set yeah that was
that was rough
but i don't know how that happened that
that second game we're talking about
yeah i i absolutely blundered i've
turned the music up
full volume i was feeling so confident
after game one
and it all fell apart it was so bad
yeah so many blunders so many blunders
honestly guys not even to grill the
chest you guys were just it was great
and thank you so much
this was uh the most exciting match i've
been a part of in either pog champs and
uh
of course jack congratulations moving on
xqc again thank you so much for for
playing again dude it was it was like
i said amazing chess thanks for uh
thanks for inviting me dude yeah thanks
for putting this together yeah also
we would love to see you back excuse me
yeah yeah i just like to add that too
yeah i just like to say thanks again i
mean for participating for really
helping
popularize both the with the original
pog chance for the second one as well
because it was
really pleasant i think a lot of your
fans and all a lot of chess fans yeah i
enjoyed it
as uh i don't like losing it especially
when it's
to the clock yeah you should have had
that last one for sure
you were winning yep
well yes i saw you checking with the
game report that you had
checkmating two they were so close to
giving that mate you're just a few
seconds away from checkmate and making
it to the next stage
very unfortunate right yeah um
these movies i would have to think about
them but i i didn't have much time on
the clock i didn't
really look at the clock because uh i
was just trying to get that checkmate at
the end
yeah well maybe in pogchamps three maybe
in pogchamps three we hope to see you be
back
yep thanks again well guys again
thanks for joining us jack again
congratulations guys good luck in the
next round
thank you thank you
all right wow that was uh that was wild
that was rough
that was it was it was just amazing that
felix joined us after such a tough loss
in in the sudden death this game he had
it he was
two moves away from checkmate
yeah you know i was gonna say that's the
thing also that i think makes it really
really hard it's like in the first one
when when he um i mean when we were in
the
when he was in the constellation bracket
it felt like he was kind of i thought he
was outplayed a little bit by ludwig
but he definitely was not outplayed in
this one so to lose losing matches which
were very close where he very easily
could have won
um i mean it's heartbreaking but he
played very well and i thought overall
it was it was great to see it was very
competitive
i think by far and away it was the most
um it was the most hype of all the
matches in either podcast one or pogba
champs two so um
those it was fantastic and like that i
mean just well and like jack said he
said well
when i was teasing him i said what was
that and he said it was great content
and he was right
it was awesome that was awesome content
and uh jack
scissors as you see there does move on
in double
sudden death tiebreaker fashion for
those of you who may be just tuning in
and and all credit to jack he also
played played well i agree this was a
could have been a coin flip match
and um and in the end he barely moves on
let's remind everybody in the remaining
schedule as we are now in the
like we said the bracket stage no longer
the group stage it's elimination time
and uh coming up we have after today
we have thor taking on tf blade connor
taking on cutie and then you have finton
easy with aces taking on
carson live i think uh all three of
those i think if everyone plays their
best chess there's maybe a slight favor
in each match but could be
could be exciting all around as well so
tune in tomorrow
september 3rd i will not be there but uh
we have uh we'll have some
incredible incredible games incredible
commentary again
anna was your first day worth it did you
enjoy it
it was absolutely worth it i want to
stay here can i can i stay
you know i'll be back on friday keep the
show going um
just on my own thank you no but honestly
this has been
such an amazing day i thought that i was
in for some treat
uh ups and downs lots of mistakes really
exciting chess but this was
even more than what i expected in every
single match of today
couldn't couldn't agree more uh hikaro
again thank you so much man this
these days continue to roll on as we get
closer to crowning another pog champs
champion
behalf of the crew here yeah it's been
great to see it's been great to see
yeah and you know someone who's like
you've been closer to xqc than anybody
in the chess community since he really
kind of took you a few months ago
today really it was awesome i know it
ended i know he's heartbroken right now
and i really and we really
appreciate that he joined us but you got
to say like he's clearly made
such strides over the last couple months
like these games were really good right
yeah yeah i think that's the thing is
like it wasn't it felt like when he
first was starting there were a lot of
points in the games when he would make
random moves there wasn't really an idea
he wasn't seeing
patterns and i felt like especially in
games one and two when he saw these
tactics tactical patterns they had
before it showed that it was clicking
and then also see this knight f6 check
as well in the final game it showed that
he was trying to see some of the
patterns so
i thought it was it was great to watch i
mean he's very unfortunate to lose that
um to lose that that match but again it
came down to a couple of seconds so if
that's what it's going to take then i
think that's a clear sign of improvement
and um
of course it it feels feels bad i mean i
think anyone would feel bad after that
but
certainly his his performance uh
fantastic
there's nothing nothing to be
disappointed if i'm excused
agreed totally and uh we will we will
see where
where this yes goes for him from here
but for us i'm gonna i'm gonna sign off
um
give a give a big shout out we're rating
uh robert hess who's doing a memorial
tournament right now so stick around for
those of you who want to join robert
and his stream and for everyone here
working hard at chess.com to make these
shows awesome
our our team the events crew the mods
everybody thank you so much
see you tomorrow on september 3rd for
more pog champs and uh
talk to you then
[Music]
you